Mobile Max, Mobile Max, that's whatever, Mobile Max does.
Wow, wir haben einen Jingle.
Wir haben einen Jingle, ja, der ist uns zugeschickt worden, beim letzten Mal. Hast du dich aufgeschrieben? Nach dem letzten Mal. Nach dem letzten Mal. Ja, dies ist eine große Herausforderung, die wir in den letzten Jahren haben, in den letzten Jahren in den letzten Jahren, in den letzten Jahren, in den letzten Jahren, auch bei Mobile Max, ha ha ha ha, Karlauer. Achso, ich muss wirklich lachen, nicht nur so tun, als ob ich lachen würde. Ja, ja, genau, du musst richtig lachen. Dein ganzes Gewedel und so, das kommt dir überhaupt nicht an, denn das ist ein Podcast. Willkommen beim Mobile Max Podcast Nummer zwei, wir haben es tatsächlich geschafft. Es sind zwar jetzt nicht genau 14 Tage geworden, glaube ich, aber Pi mal Daumen zwei Wochen. Zweimal im Monat ist doch eigentlich viel besser als 14 Tage. Klar kommt das drauf an, aber ich glaube, das schaffe ich jetzt nicht mehr. Bist du laut genug, Dennis? Ja, weiss ich nicht, ich hoffe. Wo ist denn dein Mikrofon? Ich mache dich mal ein bisschen lauter. Du bist immer so leise. Na ja, damit meine Grundgeräusche nicht so durchkommen. Okay, hallo, guten Tag, wir sind es wieder, Max, Dennis, Tim, und zwar in der Reihenfolge von links nach rechts mit Dennis, dann ich, Tim und Max. Genau, und wir machen das immer so, dass wir immer so von links nach rechts so verteilt sind, weil es kamen Fragen auf, beziehungsweise keine Fragen, sondern Aussagen, dass man nach einer Weile, wenn man hört, die Stimmen sowieso nicht mehr auseinanderhalten kann. Ja, andersrum, oder? Na, eigentlich sollte man sich dran gewöhnen. Ja. Genau, und am Anfang reden wir immer so viel Zeug. Also ich bin der, der in Zweifel zwei blöde Fragen stellt. Genau, deswegen, da haben wir ja heute auch genau die richtigen Themen. Danke. Bitte. Ja, mal gucken, also das ist mit dem Jingle-Fan ja ganz lustig irgendwie. Der ist grossartig, vielen Dank dafür. Ja genau, wir müssen, dann ist auch, mussten wir das gerade dir gerade erklären? Ne, du kanntest das auch, ne? Also es ist ja sozusagen eine... Ich habe es halt nicht wiedererkannt, weil es halt wie Max schon meinte so choral klingt. Genau, so klostermässig. Die chorale Variante vom grossartigen Spider-Pick oder eigentlich auch von Spider-Man, wenn man genau ist. Wie auch immer, vielleicht finden wir ja noch mehr... Also mir ist im Nachhinein eindeutig eingefallen, ich habe die Spider-Pick-Variante gesungen. Du hast die Spider-Pick-Variante gesungen. Ich weiß noch gar nicht, wie die Spider-Man-Variante geht, ich kenne nur die Spider-Pick-Variante. Ist die wirklich genau so? Ich habe keine Ahnung. Wir wissen es nicht. Wie auch immer, wir wollen uns nicht so lange mit dem Jingle aufhalten, sondern ein bisschen mal wieder in die Themenlandschaft gehen, aber da es erst die zweite Ausgabe ist, muss man vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen vorstellen. Also das ist der Mobile Max Podcast und wir möchten ein wenig, alle zwei Wochen oder sagen wir mal zweimal im Monat eben, die Macintosh-Themenlandschaft durchpflügen und natürlich nicht nur den Mac und umgraben, sondern auch das Telefon und iPod und all das, was sozusagen zum Apfel-Universum dazugehört. Also eigentlich Mobile Apple. Eigentlich Mobile Apple. Mist. Mist. Kommt halt nicht so cool. Das war's. Ist die Domain noch frei? Jetzt nicht mehr. Ja, letztes Mal haben wir uns ja schön ausgelassen zum iPhone und jetzt ist ja dann auch, du hast ja dieses Tool erläutert, dieses Ponic-Tool, das war aber noch nicht draußen.
Das sollte an dem Tag kommen, haben sie dann aber verzögert, weil Apple wohl irgendwie erst mal ein bisschen rumgezickt hat. Da mussten sie erst mal beweisen, dass sie keine Copyright-Verletzungen oder Apple-Software irgendwie mit integrieren, so wie bei anderen Hacks.
Und dann kam es irgendwie am Mittwoch raus oder so.
Am Mittwoch nach dem Podcast meinst du?
Ja.
Okay.
Darf ich ja dazwischen, nochmal kurz dazwischengegen, es ist ja unglaublich, dass du wirklich, während wir das jetzt aufnehmen, live dein iPhone breakst. Ja, ich habe hier gerade rumgespielt und weil ich weiterhin empfangen und erreichbar sein will, hacke ich es gerade um, aber nicht halt mit diesem Pornostuhl, sondern ganz normal mit diesem, ja, ich sage immer Zip-Phone dazu, dieses Z-iPhone und das läuft halt so nebenbei und funktioniert. Schick aus. Ah, das hat auch noch so ein Zorro-Z dann auf dem Screen. Genau, hat er irgendwie neu gemacht, weil er ist ja auch eh gut. Aber warum musst du das jetzt nochmal machen? Das hattest du doch gemacht. Ich habe es gerade irgendwie in den Restore-Modus gebracht, weil ich es eigentlich richtig mit diesem Pornage-Tool öffnen wollte und das das hat aber immer noch nicht funktioniert. Und deswegen muss ich jetzt wieder die alte, originale Apple-Software einspielen. Und da ich ja keinen Telekom-Dings-Vertrag habe, muss ich es dann auch noch anlocken. Aha. Das heisst, das Pornet-Tool funktioniert nicht? Das hat vor zehn Tagen oder so hat es funktioniert mit einer älteren Version. Ich habe halt jetzt gerade die neue Version probiert.
Welche neue Version?
Es gibt seit dem 14., also vorgestern, die Version 1.1 von dem Pornach-Tool, mit der auch die allerneueste 2.0-Firmware irgendwie auf dem iPhone gebracht werden kann.
Und hast du die schon? Die habe ich.
Die habe ich nicht.
Natürlich nicht. Nee, darf ich gar nicht, oder? Darf ich? Weiss ich gar nicht. Nee, dann habe ich die auch nicht. Die gibt es auf jeden Fall. Dieses Pornostool unterstützt das. Ja. Und dann kann man sich die einspielen. Okay. Hui. Aber es funktioniert nicht. Ich wollte mich reinlegen. Aber es funktioniert nicht immer. Nee. Also beim letzten Mal hat es funktioniert. Da ging es. Aber die aktuelle geht gerade nicht. Aber zumindest ist es keine Vaporware. Ne, es funktioniert wirklich und es geht und so und jo. Das heisst, es ist jetzt davon auszugehen, dass dann eben auch zukünftige Versionen, wie wir das da letztes Mal schon angedacht haben, auch tatsächlich Ja, der Bootloader sorgt halt dafür, dass man einspielen kann, was man will und deswegen können die jetzt schon die Firmware ändern oder aufhacken, bevor sie auf dem Telefon landet. Vorher mussten sie das einmal aufhacken, während es schon auf dem Telefon drauf ist und dann haben sie ja nicht mehr alle möglichen Zugriffe, also mussten ja Exploits nutzen und jetzt, selbst wenn es keine Exploits mehr geben würde, wäre total egal, weil sie einfach vorher den Code ändern können und dann spielen sie einfach ihren geänderten Code ein. Aber was ich, entweder habe ich es jetzt schon wieder vergessen oder das letzte Mal nicht so richtig verstanden. Also dieses Pwnage-Tool klingt sich in iTunes ein, richtig? Ne. Sondern? Es ist ein eigenständiges Tool. Also das Pwnage-Tool installiert erstmal, macht das Update dieses Basebands, diese Firmware. Gehe dazwischen, wenn ich etwas Falsches sage. Ich gehe mal dazwischen. Geh mal dazwischen, dann erklärst du es. Das Pornage-Tool, die Leute, dieses Dev-iPhone-Team oder iPhone-Dev-Team, die haben halt den Bootloader neu geschrieben. Und der Bootloader prüft eigentlich die Signatur der Images, die da eingespielt werden, zum Beispiel auch vom Baseband. Und der Bootloader prüft die Signaturen jetzt halt nicht mehr, sondern nimmt einfach alles, was er kriegt, und deswegen
können sie jetzt auch einspielen, was
sie wollen. Ja gut, aber das Einspielen
steht dann übereit. Ja, aber wie kommt dieser
modifizierte Bootloader aufs Phone?
Den kann man halt auch upgraden.
Über?
Dieses Programm, über dieses Pornage-Tool.
Das heisst, das Tool schreibt
über das Interface direkt auf diesen Bootloader. Welches Interface? Na, das Kabel, was ich da gerade sehe, über USB. Also er lässt es nicht iTunes machen, sondern er macht selber das Device auf. Er schreibt direkt da drauf. Und wie kann das sein, dass das Tool direkt den Bootloader überschreiben kann, wenn es über USB an irgendwas angeschlossen ist? Ich glaube, das wird nicht direkt über USB gemacht, sondern sie schieben per USB ein Pfeil drauf, was dann beim Booten sich startet. So eine Art Outro-Starter-Exact-Dingsbums. Ja, der Sibri macht das ja auch so, dieses Z-iPhone-Tool, der schiebt da Pfeils drauf, dann wird gebootet und dann werden die beim Booten gestartet und dann patcht das sich selbst und dann bootet er weiter. Deswegen bootet er auch zweimal, glaube ich. Jedes Mal oder nur einmal? Das Z-iPhone bootet, glaube ich, ne, ne, nur beim ersten Mal aufmachen, danach nicht mehr, danach sind die Tools ja weg, dann braucht man ja nicht mehr. Und ich habe gehört, dass das sozusagen jetzt insofern nicht reversibel ist seitens Apple, weil sie irgendwie nicht in der Lage sind, diesen Bootloader zu updaten. Hast du da sowas auch gehört? Das habe ich auch gehört, aber man kann ja den Bootloader updaten. Ich weiss noch nicht, es kann sein, dass iTunes die Baseband updatet und die Firmware updatet, aber den Bootloader eventuell nicht. Aber es ist unklar, ob sie das nicht vielleicht auch, ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen, dass... Na, man könnte jetzt mit einer neuen Software enforcen oder erzwingen halt, dass ein bestimmter Bootloader da ist. Das ist ja aber egal, weil sie diesen Hack jetzt immer schon vorher wieder rausnehmen können. Nicht diesen Hack, sondern diesen Test. Deswegen können die ja eigentlich einbauen, was sie wollen. Sie können es natürlich sehr schwer und umständlich machen, dass wirklich jedes Tool immer das checkt,
aber das ist ja auch wieder nicht Apple-Style.
Ja, aber wenn jetzt Apple irgendwie die Finale 2.0 rausbringt, hält sie irgendwas davon ab,
dieses iPhone wirklich komplett mit diesem Update so wegzuwipen und einen neuen Bootloader draufzumachen,
der dann erstmal wieder neu geknackt werden müsste?
Ich meine, Sie müssen doch auch in der Lage sein, Ihren Bootloader zu aktualisieren.
Das ist doch nicht in der Lage, Ihr Telefon wirklich im Griff zu kriegen.
Das ist egal, ob Sie einen Bootloader haben, der nicht geknackt wird, weil ja das Pornostool sowieso immer den kompletten Neuschreiben kann im Restore-Modus.
Das heisst, du kannst auch immer eine alte Version aufspielen, dadurch kannst du auch immer den gehackten Bootloader einspielen. Und merkt es, dass es sich in den letzten Jahren auch in den letzten Jahren auch in den letzten Jahrhunderten und in den letzten Jahren auch in den letzten Jahren auch in den letzten Jahren auch in den letzten weit ändert, dass der alte gehackte Bootloader nicht mehr in der Lage ist, das neue System wirklich zu booten. Da müssten aber echt ganz schön viel ändern. Na ja, die werden sich mit Händen und Füssen wehren, denk ich mal.
Nö, denk ich nicht.
Denkst du nicht?
Nö.
Warum?
Also erstens, weil es wirklich sehr kompliziert wäre und das am Ende auch keine Rolle spielt,
Die wollen ja Telefone verkaufen.
Naja, gut, aber dafür wehren sie sich ja schon ganz schön dagegen. Also ich glaube, sie müssen sich wehren, weil sonst verlieren sie ihre GSM oder sonstige Lizenzen, aber ansonsten sind die doch auch froh, dass sie Telefone verkaufen. Das glaube ich nicht, dass sie ihre GSM-Lizenzen. Ich denke, dass sie Stress mit den Providern kriegen, mit denen sie ihre Verträge haben, weil AT&T wahrscheinlich so eine Klausel drin hat und wenn irgendwie Software aufkommt, so ein bisschen wie mit dem DRM bei iTunes, so nach dem Motto, wo die Musikverlage verpflichten, Apple, wenn irgendwie herzbekannt ist, was dagegen zu tun, dass die halt auch sozusagen dagegen vorgehen müssen, auch wenn es ihnen irgendwie ein bisschen Wurst ist. Habe ich auch gedacht, dass die so Verträge haben, so innerhalb von vier Wochen muss so ein Exploit irgendwie dicht gemacht werden, aber die 1-1-4 ist jetzt seit, ich weiss nicht, 20. Februar draussen oder so, und jetzt ist schon wieder bald 20.04. Das heisst, auch seit zwei Monaten haben die da nichts dicht gemacht. Das 114 war ja innerhalb von Minuten auch geheckt. Nee, die 114 war, glaube ich, auch überhaupt gar keine Änderung.
Na, die Stelle, wo sie den Heck angebracht haben, hat sich ein Stück verschoben, so wie ich das verstanden habe.
Sie mussten nur die neue Stelle finden, aber der Exploit war der gleiche wie vorher. Okay, verstehe. Unklar. Naja, tja. Aber es sieht schon so aus, als wenn es wirklich das iPhone sehr offen ist. Also die Pornish-Tools oder die Pornish-Jungs, die wissen da schon ganz genau, was sie da tun. Zumindest trägt es nicht dazu bei, dass sich das iPhone besonders gut verkauft in Deutschland, hat man so den Eindruck. Ja, nicht bei der Telekom. Nicht bei der Telekom. Aber guck mal auf Ebay. Ja, was ist denn auf Ebay? Da ist die Hölle los. Weil alle verkaufen wieder ihre bereits gekauften Telefone, aber. Ne, es sind keine bereits gekauauften, es sind grau importierte. Naja, die sind sie ja schon bereits gekauft.
Du meinst, in Deutschland werden die Leute nur...
Kaufen ganz viele...
Die in Deutschland benutzten Telefone tragen US-amerikanischen Statistik bei.
Naja, also ob das nun wirklich so eine Menge ist, das weiss ich nicht.
Also ich kenne mehr Leute mit amerikanischem iPhone als mit deutschem iPhone. Ja, ich auch. Was für Preise werden da so derzeit erzielt? Na, wir können ja erstmal sagen, was es normal ohne Gewinn kosten würde, eins aus Amerika mitzubringen, das ist umgerechnet so 270 Euro. So, dann wenn der die Person halt, du kannst ja nicht zehn Stück irgendwie von drüben mitbringen, das sind schon immer, irgendwer ist gerade in Amerika und bringt ein oder zwei Stück mit und dann gehen die halt so weg. Ich weiss nicht, ob es so Profi-Grau-Importeure gibt, die das in grösseren Massen machen, wahrscheinlich schon. Gibt's auf jeden Fall. Ich habe gehört, dass das für Airline-Mitarbeiter, für Fluglinien-Mitarbeiter ein schönes Nebengeschäft sein soll, regelmäßig mal iPhones mitzubringen, die dann in China wohl gerne landen. Ja stimmt, die sind ja die ganze Zeit über den Teich. Stewardessen. Stewardessen. An die müssen ja reich sein. Naja, ob so viel Geld noch zu machen ist, jetzt gibt es das iPhone ja billiger. Telekom hat ja, also zumindest das 8-Gigabyte-Modell wird jetzt doch ganz schön verkloppt, verramscht. Wir haben auch einen neuen Tarif, der kostet jetzt nur noch 29 Euro anstatt 49. Dafür ist auch nicht mehr flat, sondern man hat nur noch 500 MB pro Monat. Nicht nur das, und auch die Hotspot-Nutzung fällt weg. Und keine freie SMS mehr. Und keine freie SMS. Ah ja, also ganz schön beschnitten, finde ich. Allerdings, was ich nicht verstehe ist, also da sind sind ja dann immer noch diese Telefonkontingente drin, oder? Da sind ja ein paar drin, ja auf jeden Fall. Aber es gibt so das Gegenteil nicht. Also was ist mit Leuten, die eigentlich mehr an der Internetfunktionalität Interesse haben, aber so sehr am Telefonieren nicht? Also ich würde ja dann mit niedrigeren Kontingenten, aber dann eben trotzdem mit Flat Internet und Hotspots zuhören. Das finde ich ja das Interessante. Aber so Telefonieren, mein Gott. Ich glaube, so was tragt in der Vorstellungswelt des Telekom-Mitarbeiters nicht auf. Ja, das ist überhaupt das Problem, glaube ich, dass einfach dieses iPhone ein Gerät ist, was in der Vorstellungswelt der Telekom einfach nicht stattfindet. So, wobei Kleintarif sind nur 50 Minuten inklusive dabei, das ist schon für jemanden, der gar nicht telefoniert eigentlich. Wie viel? 50 Minuten. Aber die Vegan-Flare ist trotzdem dabei. Also am Wochenende darf man doch telefonieren. Aber das ist alles so kompliziert. Das ist eben das, was ich nicht verstehe. Jetzt haben Sie den zweiten Tarifwechsel, seitdem Sie das Teil auf den Markt gebracht haben, und das ist noch nicht so lange her. Also man weiss jetzt schon nicht mehr, was überhaupt Sache ist, was ich schon mal echt katastrophal finde, weil ich denke, ein Ding beim iPhone von Anfang an war auch diese einfache Tarifstruktur. Da gibt es einfach klein, mittel, gross, fertig aus, und in den USA hat es sich damit irgendwie wunderbar verkauft.
Jetzt gibt es klein, mittel, gross und billig.
Und hier gab es zwar auch klein, mittel, gross, aber das Klein war einfach nicht klein genug, um wirklich Interesse zu wecken, und jetzt ist ja auch noch der Verkaufspreis gestaffelt.
Also ich habe mir mal die österreichischen T-Mobile-Tarife angeguckt und die sind ja wesentlich spannender als die deutschen, wie ich finde.
Also für so einen österreichischen, das klingt durchaus ganz interessant.
Wieso?
Ich glaube, da ist für 39 Euro, was hat man da, so und so viel hundert Minuten freie Gespräche.
Das müsste man jetzt irgendwann mal gucken.
Ach, das habe ich gar nicht mitbekommen. Das macht auch T-Mobile, ja?
Das macht auch T-Mobile.
Aha, aha, ja, ja. Wir haben ja noch eine Wette laufen, weisst du noch? Wir haben da noch eine Frage, dass wir die Frage, dass wir die Frage, dass wir die Frage, dass wir die Frage, dass wir die Frage, dass wir die Frage, dass wir, ich habe den Artikel extra noch mal rausgesucht. Und ihr habt echt nicht Smartphones gehabt. Ich habe gesagt, das iPhone wird einschlagen wie eine Bombe und du hast gesagt, du hast ja eine Meise. Ja, genau. Und da habe ich gesagt, du bist doof und dann haben wir uns geschlagen, glaube ich. Nee, dann haben wir gewettet. Ah, stimmt. Und irgendwie eine Kisse-Mate steht irgendwie an, den Besitzer zu wechseln. Und ich habe gesagt, dass bis Mai irgendwann mal so eine Meldung kommen wird, dass das iPhone das meistverkaufte Telefon in Deutschland ist. Und da sie den Preis gerade gesenkt haben, sieht das eher nicht so danach aus. Naja, oder jetzt wird es genau dazu führen. Hast du Kontakte zum Telekom-Vorstand und hast gesagt, hallo, da steht eine Kriste Marte an, senkt mal die Preise. Wenn ich die hätte, würde ich die nie zugeben. Ah, okay, gut. Also, oh, da habe ich noch so ein gewisses Mysterium aufrechterhalten. Also wenn ihr um Smartphones gewettet hättet, dann wäre es ja vielleicht noch spannend, aber so glaube ich, ist es ja eindeutig nicht zu gewinnen.
Naja, ich habe so ein bisschen, mein Trick war so ein bisschen, dass ich davon ausgegangen bin, dass die Telefonlandschaft nach Modellen sowieso dermassen zersplittert ist. Also es werden zwar sicherlich noch mehr Telefone als Smartphones verkauft werden, aber da Nokia pro Kunde ein Telefon im Angebot hat. So viele verschiedene andere, verstehe. Es gibt so viele verschiedene Modelle, dass ich dachte, aber dann ist die Wette ja auch nicht gewinnen oder verlierbar, weil man ja die Zahlen nicht kriegt, oder? Ja, ob die überhaupt noch mal richtige Zahlen rausschmeissen, steht noch mal auf dem anderen Blatt. Also das meistverkaufte Smartphone könnte trotzdem noch irgendwie greifen. Zwar nutzten wir es einfach so. Aber es sieht irgendwie komisch aus. Man hat irgendwie das Gefühl, das findet nicht statt. Ich bin auch mal in so einen Telekom-Laden reingegangen und wollte mir mal ein iPhone verkaufen lassen. So einfach mal, mach doch mal ein Verkaufsgespräch. Das war sehr schwierig. Es fing schon damit an, ich habe mir das Ding angeguckt, da war das halt Version 1.1.2. Das ist noch gar nicht so lange her, wo also noch nicht mal das Location-Feature drauf ist. So, und dann meinte ich so, naja, hier Telefon irgendwie, nicht aktuelle Software, habt ihr sie noch alle? Ich meine, ich bin einfach mal Apple Store gewöhnt, verstehst du, wo man, wo man, wo man gebildete, ich war jetzt gerade mal wieder im Apple Store, das ist einfach so was anderes, ja, also ausgebildete, freundliche, zuvorkommende Mitarbeiter, die sich an, was, du warst im Ausland, ich war im Ausland, und im Ausland läuft die Sache einfach anders, und hier verkauft Apple Apple das halt einfach und das auch noch exklusiv, das verstehe ich ja nun überhaupt nicht, exklusiv in diesen Telekom-Leben. Also dass sie nicht da auch noch einen Deal mit Gravis geschnitzt haben, verstehe ich nicht. Bei Gravis gibt es jetzt aber, als ich das letzte Mal dabei, gibt es da so einen kleinen T-Punkt im Gravis-Store. Ach, ist das jetzt so weit? Ja, wo es dann iPhones zu kaufen gibt und natürlich auch andere Geräte. Aber dann so mit Magenta oder was? So ein bisschen mit Magenta, so ganz kleiner Stand da mittendrin, zumindest hier am Ernst-Reuter-Platz. Da verkaufen sie dann nur das iPhone? Ne, ne, da verkaufen sie auch sonstiges. Also es ist so ein kleiner T-Punkt da mitten im Laden. Und es ist ja unmöglich, ich habe probiert für mein iPhone endlich mal so eine Tasche zum Joggen zu kriegen, damit ich mir das umarmen kann, da gibt es irgendwie von irgendeinem Hersteller, gibt es auch nicht im T-Punkt, es gibt keine iPhone-Taschen im T-Punkt normalerweise zu kaufen, das bei Grafen greift einfach nicht. Das ist genau, es greift einfach überhaupt nicht. Also es ist einfach die Tatsache, dass es hier auch keine Apple-Stores gibt, die mal ordentlich Kongress machen. Ich meine, das wird sich jetzt bald ändern. In München macht einer auf. Ich weiss noch nicht genau wann, aber lange kann es nicht mehr dauern, weil sie suchen schon Mitarbeiter. Ich schätze mal, das wird dieses Jahr noch irgendwann stattfinden. Warum sie jetzt ausgerechnet wieder in München starten mussten, habe ich nicht so ganz verstanden, aber naja gut, Apple Deutschland ist in München und so und überhaupt ist immer diese ganze IT-Branche in München und ich weiss immer nicht warum. Also geholfen hat es nicht viel, finde ich. Oder? Also ich finde den Zustand, einfach so IT-Firmen in Deutschland, überhaupt so IT in Deutschland, ist einfach immer noch langweilig und doof. Tja, tja, tja, tja. Also aber auch mit dieser Telekom, das wird nichts. Meine, wo haben Sie bitte das iPhone verkauft am ersten Tag? Wo haben Sie Ihren Release gemacht? Ah stimmt, in Köln? Köln. Wow. Also nix gegen Köln. Aber doch vier gegen Köln. Naja,
es gibt wirklich Wo haben Sie Ihren Release gemacht? Ah stimmt, in Köln. In Köln. Wow. Also nix gegen Köln.
Aber doch viel gegen Köln.
Naja, es gibt wirklich, wie auch immer, aber das geht einfach nicht.
Ich meine, wenn man irgendwie, wenn man einen Dicken machen will, dann macht man das doch
nicht in so einem Laden in Köln.
Kann man das nicht in mehreren Läden machen? Ja, man hätte alles möglich tun können, aber es ist wirklich so. Ja, aber unsere Zentrale ist doch auch in Köln. Die ist doch in Bonn. Naja, Köln, Bonn, das ist jetzt kein, ich weiss, dass jetzt die Bonner, die zuhören und die Kölner, die zuhören, die haben jetzt schon so einen dicken Hals, aber so will ich das jetzt. Von Kölnern, Kölnern. Das ist halt einfach geografisch beieinander und die haben da wohl irgendeinen dicken Tee-Punkt in Köln, keine Ahnung.
Aber den haben sie im Zweifelsfall nicht genommen.
Auf jeden Fall finde ich einfach, die verstehen einfach den Vibe nicht.
Also die begreifen einfach überhaupt nicht, was für ein heisses Produkt sie da am Start haben und wie sie das irgendwie nutzen können.
Und sie geben sich alle Mühe, das auch zu verderben, habe ich manchmal so ein bisschen das Gefühl.
Ja, und deswegen wird es einfach schwierig mit meiner Wette. Mal gucken. Aber dieser Tarif könnte auf jeden Fall was bringen. Immerhin kann man sich ja jetzt ein iPhone für 99 Euro kaufen. Wenn man bereit ist, 138.000 Euro, ich glaube so viel war es. Muss man denn den Vertrag abschliessen? Ja, das ist doch in Deutschland, das ist doch auch ein bisschen anders als in Amerika. Aber man macht das doch danach trotzdem mit iTunes. Ja, aber das ist deutsche Gründlichkeit. Ja, wir haben das Prinzip aus Amerika übernommen, wir machen die Aktivierung mit iTunes, aber vorher im Laden muss man trotzdem seinen Ausweis vorzeigen und macht trotzdem den Vertragsabschluss im Geschäft. Was macht man dann noch mit dem iTunes? Da macht man nochmal die Aktivierung oder wie auch immer. Also das hat den Teil eigentlich noch nicht durchgemacht, aber es ist, du stehst... Also der eigentliche Gedanke, glaube ich, hinter diesem Aktivierungsprozess beim iPhone ist ja, man geht in den Laden, gibt seine Kreditkarte hin, ritsch-ratsch und geht raus und ist glücklich und hat ein kurzes Einkaufserlebnis, ohne da grossartig lange rumstehen zu müssen. Dieses Prinzip wurde von der Telekom in Deutschland so weit verstanden, dass sie gesagt haben, ah, die wollen unbedingt den iTunes aktivieren. Und haben aber das dann so gemacht, dass man auch in Deutschland eben den Vertrag quasi im Geschäft abschliesst. Also auch mit dem iPhone. Genau. Und dann darf man nach Hause gehen und in iTunes noch einmal OK drücken, sozusagen. Ich glaube, genau so, ja. Das ist ja auch der Grund, warum das alles Grauenport aus Amerika sind, weil hier kann man sie ja nicht kaufen. Verstehe. Das heisst jetzt aber, läuft das denn in Britannien ähnlich, weil O2 verkauft das iPhone jetzt auch billiger. Ja, seit Ende Juni, sondern nur bis Ende Mai, wo du ja vorhin schon so schön mirakeln wolltest, dass Ende Juni sozusagen die Zeit des UMTS-iPhone, weil sie in der neuesten Zwei-Nuller-Beta-Firmware den String S-Gold 3H gefunden haben.
Das ist der Nachfolgechip von Infineon, also der Nachfolgechip des jetzigen iPhones, und der kann dann auch HS, DPA und WC, DMA, tralala, also UMTS.
Der kann auch Videoaufnahmen, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht? Ja, der Chip kann halt eine ganze Menge, also ich glaube, der jetzige macht das da auch schon, oder nicht? Ich weiss nicht, unterstützt eine höhere Auflösung für Kameras und sowas. Hast du auch HS, UPA gelesen? Ich glaube ja, ne? Ne, ich glaube, das hat es ihm noch nicht, bin mir nicht so ganz sicher. Kann ich mir ja nicht vorstellen. Das ist aber nur für schnelleren Upload, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe. Ja, UPA ist Upload und DPA ist Download. Ja, aber es ist schon ein ganz, der Infinity-Chip hat schon Support für den neuen 7,2 Mbit Hsdpa. Heisst das so, jetzt komme ich langsam durcheinander bei den ganzen Tutschen. Ja, es gibt Hsdpa in zwei Stufen, es gibt das 3,6 Mbit und das sind nur zwei Mbit. Und der hat auch schon 7,2. Ja, okay. Also wenn das jetzt wirklich ein neuer Stein ist. Und der soll ja in Australien kommen, ohne Locking, also so ein UMTS-Telefon, und zwar Datum Ende Juni. Der Stein, der Chip. Das Telefon, munkelt man gerade so. Das iPhone. Ja, das nächste. In Australien. Was hat denn Australien für eine Netzstruktur? Haben die auch nur UMTS? Keine Ahnung. Hm, Australien. Das habe ich noch nicht gelesen. Also Australien weiß ich nicht, aber... Also es wäre der nächste Hinweis auf Ende Juni und die Telekom-Aktion geht bis Ende Juni. Wobei, die Telekom hat, glaube ich, so was von keinem blassen Schimmer von dem, was da haargenau abgeht. Ich glaube, die werden so was von im Dunkeln gelassen. Das glaube ich allerdings auch, dass die nicht wirklich genau wissen, was Sache ist. Die werden am Ende noch ihr Projekt zurückstecken müssen. Auf jeden Fall habe ich das Gefühl, dass ihre Telefone nicht schneller loswerden. Mich stimmt das irgendwie nicht glücklich, was die deutsche Telekom da macht. Man muss sagen, diese deutsche Strategie ist irgendwie verkackt. Ich weiss nicht, wie es in Frankreich aussieht, aber das ist einfach alles nicht schön. Aber es liegt vor allem daran, dass es keine Apple-Stores gibt. Aber nochmal zum OMTS-Fonds, ich meine, dass ein OMTS-Fonds kommt, das ist schon lange geklärt.
Ja, und dass sie den Nachfolgechip nehmen, ist eigentlich auch da.
Ich frage mich nur gerade eins, weil vor ein paar Monaten ist doch bekannt geworden, dass Apple sich eine Lizenz für UMTS-Technologie von Interdigital hat geben lassen. Die haben Millionen ausgegeben an Interdigital und die machen halt UMTS-Technologieentwicklung. Jetzt frage ich mich, warum muss Apple eine Lizenz kaufen, wenn sie einen Chip von Infineon nehmen? Vielleicht für die nächste Generation oder für die nächste oder für die danach oder für... Warum sollten sie jetzt zwei verschiedene Generationen... Kein Gerücht, sondern Fakt. Das ist Fakt. Den Ding kann ich nochmal raussuchen.. Ich kann nicht mehr in den Post mit rein, aber die haben halt das gekauft, das ist bekannt gegeben worden. Das habe ich gar nicht mitbekommen. Ja, bei Interdigital. Und das muss irgendwie, ja, und das ist halt sozusagen, wir machen hier die Next Generation UMTS. Aber haben die denn einen eigenen Chip? Nein, die verkaufen die Technologie. Also die haben die Lizenz verkauft, die machen das Chip-Design, aber die bauen die Dinger nicht. Die entwickeln sozusagen um TS-Technologie und ja, und Apple hat diese Lizenz erworben. Was mich so ein bisschen in diesen Gedanken bringt, so, dann könnte Apple sich ja sozusagen ihren eigenen Stein bauen. Aber ich meine, vielleicht machen sie es ja ähnlich wie beim iPod, wo sie ja am Anfang auch sehr, sehr oft die Hardware und auch die Software von Drittherstellern zurückgegriffen haben.
Und dann zunehmendem war es eine eigene Entwicklung.
Und nach und nach das alles selbst gemacht haben.
Aber das wurde halt nicht zu diesem aktuellen S-Gold-3-Dingsbums.
Vielleicht ist der einfach noch nicht so weit.
Aber wenn das wirklich in der Firmware drin ist, dann ist das auch nicht so ungewöhnlich.
Also ich muss sagen, das ist der erste Hinweis, den ich wirklich ernst nehme, dass in einer Beta von einer 2.0-Version plötzlich dann dieser Hinweis auf den Chip auftaucht. Also dieses so, oh, wir haben gehört und sowas. Da gibt es immer eine Menge von, ja. Da gibt es eine Menge von, aber dieser, also es klingt logisch, dass mit einer neuen Firmenwär, also mit dem ersten grossen Schritt ein neues Telefon auch kommt. Und weil dann wird es wahrscheinlich auch neue Möglichkeiten geben, die jetzt noch nicht bekannt sind, meinetwegen YouTube, Upload oder bessere Qualität oder irgendwie sowas, da ist doch garantiert noch irgendwas in der Hinterhand, was noch nicht erwähnt wurde, ansonsten wäre es ja auch keine Firmware 2.0 mit den dreieinhalb Neuerungen, die bisher kamen und dann der Hinweis in der Firmware darauf, dass plötzlich tatsächlich dieser Chip erwähnt wird und dass da offensichtlich irgendwelche Bibliotheken einkompiliert sind. Das klingt mir plausibel zumindest. Wir werden es sehen. Ist ja auch nur noch acht Wochen. Es sind ja nur noch viele Monate und viele Mobile-Max-Podcasts hin. Zwei Monate, ist ja nichts. Ja, also ich meine, ich würde es jetzt nicht für total unwahrscheinlich halten, dass es Mitte des Jahres schon kommt, weil Sie wollen ja auch im Laufe, was war Ihre Ankündigung für den Asienmarkt im Laufe des Jahres 2008, Mitte des Jahres, was haben Sie gesagt? Weiss ich gar nicht mehr. Ich weiss es auch nicht mehr so ganz genau. Ich hatte immer so das Gefühl, Sie werden so Mitte des Jahres losgehen. Wenn sie in Japan einschlagen wollen, und das ist ja ihr erklärtes Ziel, dass Sie dort als nächstes kommen, müssen Sie ein UMTS-Phone haben, weil es dort einfach kein GSM gibt. Ich meine, das ist ja auch für hier eigentlich durchaus, wir sind ja auch UMTS-verwöhnt, das ist ja eigentlich auch schon. Naja, was heisst, wir sind UMTS-verwöhnt? Ich meine, das iPhone lädt über Edge die Webseiten schneller als jedes UMTS-Phone.
Ich war ja letztes Wochenende an der Ostsee und an der Ostsee gibt es irgendwie da, wo ich war, kein UMTS. Und ich habe, jetzt muss ich ja Schleichwerbung machen. Mach mal. Ich habe ja O2 und O2 switcht ja auf die Telekom um, wenn kein O2 da ist. Und per O2 hätte ich GPS gehabt mit meinem Telefon, das ist halt relativ schnarchig langsam, so fünf Kilowatt die Sekunde und eine relativ hohe Latenz von knapp einer Sekunde. Und wenn ich aber kein O2 habe, switcht es zu der Telekom und dann habe ich auch Edge und Edge flutscht mit 25 Kilowatt die Sekunde und das ist total toll. Und an der Ostsee hast du halt kein OMTS, also nützt dir das mal gar nichts, dann ist Edge total super. Das heisst, die Entscheidung, auf Edge zu setzen, was deutschlandweit existiert und in Amerika glaube ich dann auch dort, oder, weiss ich gar nicht, ist schon nicht so verkehrt. Weil was nützt dir denn das UMTS in der Stadt, wo du sowieso die ganzen WLAN-Hotspots hast, da brauchst du sowieso kein UMTS, aber wenn du mal ein bisschen rausfährst, da bräuchst du das UMTS, da ist aber keins, also ist Edge da genau die richtige Wahl. Also für die Rügner ist das iPhone perfekt quasi, so wie es ist. Na, ich war ein Weg, aber nur wenn du bei U2 eingebaut bist. Wobei, das finde ich auch lustig, auch in der Berliner U-Bahn ist es so, teilweise auf der U7, dass man da auf T-Mobile umschaltet. Und wenn ich da mit der U-Bahn fahre, habe ich auch theoretisch eine schnellere Datenverbindung, wobei von Flutschen würde
ich da auch nicht unbedingt sprechen, um ehrlich zu sagen.
Nö, Flutschen nicht, aber es ist schon okay.
Ja, es ist okay.
Für Mobil finde ich das schon ganz gut.
Aber es ist weit entfernt von dem, was ich von UMTS kenne oder Ähnlichem.
Ja, aber sonst hast du ja halt GPS.
deinem Telefon. Ja, also wie gesagt, wenn dann irgendwann mal, jo, wir wiederholen uns. Wir wiederholen uns. Bei den, ja, zum Thema schlanke mobile Geräte, kriege ich ja hier mal gleich hier diese neue Erwerbung. Was ist für eine Überleitung? Kriege ich diese elegante, also ich muss sagen, ich bin beeindruckt. Ich habe hier ein MacBook Air in meiner Hand. Er balanciert es auf einem Finger quasi. Nein, aber man kann es wirklich also problemlos so auf seinem Handteller halten, ohne dass man so dieses Gefühl hat, ich muss es jetzt mal absetzen, was beim MacBook definitiv noch der Fall ist.
Was beim MacBook, beim MacBook Pro erst recht?
Beim MacBook Pro ist ganz schlimm und vor allem man hat immer Angst, dass es irgendwie runterkajolt und so.
Und ich habe das Gefühl, dieses R bräuchte auch so zehn Sekunden bis zum Boden.
Ach, das fällt.
Ja, so wie so eine Feder links nach rechts wiegen.
Ich dachte, du drückst es eher nach unten als nach oben.
Ich halte es, dass es nicht nach oben steigt.
Ja, das ist ein sehr schönes Gerät.
Und wer mit den Schnittstellen-Limitierungen leben kann,
dem kann man das eigentlich nur empfehlen.
Und den Festplatten-Limitierungen natürlich.
80 GB.
Also ich behaupte ja, in ein, zwei Jahren haben wir alle so ein Ding. Dann ist die Technik so weit, dass... Meint er, es kommt so ein 15 Zoll MacBook Air? Das glaube ich nicht. Aber warum nicht? Ein 17 Zoll MacBook Air. Nee, aber ein 15 Zoll, das fährt doch. Wieso? 15 Zoll? Ich finde das... Ja, Platte weg, irgendwie 128 MB Flash rein, eine Gigabyte, Entschuldigung. Na, was soll denn bitte da ein 15 Zoller noch bringen? Na, leichter werden. Na ja, gut. Also ich meine, ein MacBook Pro leichter zu machen, steht sowieso mal ganz oben auf der Liste. Aber dazu müsste man halt Sachen weglassen. Und das Air ist nun ein Gerät, was halt davon lebt, dass es Dinge weglässt. Also ich glaube nicht, dass es ein 15 Zoller MacBook Air geben wird. Ja, stimmt, die Porte, ich würde es ja auch vermissen. Das glaube ich auch überhaupt nicht. Also ich finde den Bildschirm auch vollkommen ausreichend. Ich meine, du hast hier irgendwie 1280x800 Pixel, das ist volle Tastatur, das ist einfach toll. Das ist schon sehr schick. Das ist eigentlich so die Grösse mit der, ich meine, ich habe auch mit dem Macbook keinerlei Probleme. Ich dachte ja auch früher immer so, oh, Bildschirm muss gross sein und so. Was war nochmal die Auflösung, die aktuelle von Macbook Pro?
1440.
Mein Gott.
So, es sind schon mehr Pixel, aber irgendwie, ich vermisse das nicht so, wie ich das befürchtet habe.
Doch, ich schon, weil ich habe zu Hause ein Cinema-Display mit 1920 mal irgendwas und immer, wenn ich
wieder auf meinen Laptop umschalte, fehlen mir Pixel.
Also ich bin damals, als ich... Ja, wenn man immer hin und her wechselt, dann fehlt einem das natürlich, aber ich komme damit klar. Es ist nicht so, dass man irgendwie das Internet nicht mehr benutzen könnte. Es ist nicht so, was weiß ich, 640 mal 480, das wäre eine echte Beschränkung. Oder auch so 800 mal 600, was man so früher hatte, aber diese Auflösung ist einfach super. Die ist okay, aber es ist, ach, es ist furchtbar leicht. Es ist ein unglaublich schöner Rechner. Und habt ihr euch auch einen USB-Hub gekauft? Es ist auch wunderbar stabil. Ich habe mir gerade einen USB-Hub gekauft, aber das hat wenig damit zu tun. Ich muss auch unbedingt noch mal meine Behauptung überprüfen, weil da gab es auch Widerspruch in den Kommentaren, dass die OS USB-Hubs, wenn da jetzt ein 1.0 und ein 2.0-Gerät angeschlossen ist, automatisch runterschalten. Hat da jemand von euch Erfahrung? Ich hätte jetzt leider keine Zeit, das zu überprüfen. Meinst du das jetzt ein Macbook-Air-Problem oder ein USB-Problem? Das ist insofern ein Macbook-Air-Problem, als dass das Macbook-Air nur einen USB-Port hat. Und wenn du da jetzt einen Hub anschließt und der runterschaltet und der runter... Du hast da eine 2.0-Platte dran und eine 1.0-Maus. Aber ist das denn so? Aber das kannst du da in Höhe, da kann man nichts herausfinden. Kann ich jetzt einfach gerade mal nicht so richtig behaupten. Wir liefern das nach als Ergebnis. Wir liefern das nach, wir fordern euch auch auf, da kluge Kommentare zu geben. Unsere Leser sollen das mal machen, dann haben wir auch auch gleich mehrere Leser. Tatsächlich, wir haben ja keine Leser. Stimmt, doch, wir haben auch Löser, wir sind ja auch im Lock. Löser? Löser. Den Blörer. ZDF. Wir müssen gleich noch über ZDF reden. Ich verplapper mich den ganzen Tag. Also mal kurz zurückspulen, wir wollen, dass unsere Hörer und Leser das rausfinden, weil dann haben wir auch mehrere Ergebnisse und nicht nur eins und dann ist es gleich. Genau, das wäre eigentlich mal sehr interessant. Also wenn irgendjemand von euch Erfahrungen hat mit Mixed-Mode-Betrieb an einem USB-Hub, also USB 1.0-Devices und 2.0-Devices, ob da wirklich automatisch runtergeschaltet wird, das wäre mal eine interessante Information. Kann man das nicht eigentlich relativ einfach rauskriegen, indem wir einfach mal einen Test machen? Ja, aber das kriegen Ja, aber das kriegen wir jetzt hier nicht hin. Ja, deswegen lassen wir es ja auch die Leser machen, die Hörer. Genau. Mein Schreibtisch ist jetzt auch gerade, ich bin zu unorganisiert gerade, hier ist einfach alles ein grosses Tova-Buch auf diesem Schreibtisch. Und ich bewundere immer noch dieses Macbook. Es ist wirklich, es ist wirklich flach. Es ist wirklich flach. Irgendjemand meinte, man könnte sich das ja nicht kaufen, ein Mädel meinte, sie wäre so rumgelaufen, überall gäbe es diese Werbung von Apple und sie meinte immer, das dümmste Notebook der Welt, warum sollte man das denn kaufen?
ein bisschen daneben. Ich finde es so unglaublich schön,
wie das Scharnier gibt fantastisch auf. Also es ist wirklich super verarbeitet auch. Es ist vor allem auch so verwindungssteif. Also es ist einfach verwindungssteifer als alles andere, was ich bisher von Apple gesehen habe. Also ich glaube, es ist das, es ist der Laptop, den Steve Jobs persönlich benutzt und darum musste da auch besonders viel Arbeit reingesteckt werden. Kann gut sein. Ich glaube nicht, dass der mit dem Macbook probiert. Ich glaube, das Ding wird sich ganz gut verkaufen.
Alle Sachen, die er persönlich benutzt, kommen ja auch als Produkt.
Also ich meine, er sagt halt, was er haben will, und dann wird es halt erstellt.
So wie Keynote, hat er halt gesagt, ich brauche jetzt mal ein ordentliches Programm zum irgendwie profilen.
Ja, wurde auch mal Zeit.
Ja, und dann hat er gesagt, ich will jetzt mal ein ordentliches Telefon haben. Ich wüsste auch noch so ein Programm, was es mal geben müsste. Habe ich auch schon mal drüber geschrieben, vielleicht erinnerst du dich. Was mich ja wirklich ankotzt, ist ja iTunes. iTunes ist auch wirklich furchtbar. Hatten wir das nicht auch schon beim letzten Mal? Nee. Doch, ich glaube so einen kleinen iTunes-Rand hatten wir auch beim letzten Mal. Naja, vielleicht haben wir ein bisschen abgerantet, aber man kann das eigentlich nicht häufig genug machen. Ja, nee, das ist schlimm. Aber immerhin hier, Apple scheint ja Erfolg zu haben. Es gab die Meldung, dass sie jetzt tatsächlich sogar Walmart im Verkauf von Musik überholt haben. Also iTunes ist jetzt quasi der grösste Musikeinzelhändler in Amerika, wenn ich das richtig
verstehe. Genau. Das heisst, sie
schieben einfach mehr Songs
über den Tisch als jeder
andere. Wollen wir da mal kurz applaudieren?
In den USA. Ja, es ist schon
ja, haben sie gut gemacht.
Und das, obwohl ihnen die
Musikindustrie gerade versucht, so kräftig
in die Eier zu treten, wie es nur irgendwie
geht, indem sie ihnen keine DRM-freien Songs geben. Na, wir haben ja schon ein paar, so ist ja nicht. Sie haben nur Emi. Ja, nur Emi ist aber auch der Grösste, glaube ich. Nee, Emi ist der kleinste. Von allen Vieren? Von allen Vieren. Und Amazon hat, glaube ich, alle ohne DRM. Also Universal ist definitiv grösser und vor allem sind alle drei zusammen auf jeden Fall
mehr als 75%. Ja, das schon.
Und von daher ist es echt
hardcore. Ja, genau. Und Amazon hat halt alles
in frei. Ja, wir sind ja auch
schon auf dem zweiten Platz.
Also im Online-Sale. Ja. Nicht im
überhaupt Sale. Ja, okay.
Naja, aber das,
ich weiss nicht, also mir, also
ich finde das ja schon so ein bisschen unlauter, also ob Apple da klagen könnte. Weil die da ausgebremst werden? Ja. Ich glaube, die brauchen ja gar nicht klagen. Ich glaube, die haben sich immer noch ganz gut im Griff. Meinst du nicht? Naja, also ich kaufe da nichts. Ich auch nicht. Ist nicht lossless. Hatten wir aber letztes Mal schon. Das hatten wir schon, aber das stört mich nicht so sehr. Aber das DRM stört mich halt schon. Vor allem, weil es halt kein Tool gibt, mit dem man das einfach entfernen kann. Es wird ja irgendwie auch viel gejubelt, aber ich glaube, der DRM wird uns noch eine Weile erhalten bleiben. Also bei den Videos macht das ja echt Sinn. Muss man ja mal so sagen. Also für die Industrie auf jeden Fall, klar. Für Rental ist es eigentlich ... Geht ja nicht anders, sonst brauchst du ja nicht Rental machen. Ja. Es ist der gleiche Kauf. Man könnte die Dateien so gross machen, dass man sie nicht auf der Festplatte aufheben kann. Man könnte sogar sagen, für Rental ist DRM sogar echt okay, oder?
Ja klar, weil du gehst ja mit dem Anspruch ran, dass du es nur für zwei Tage hast. Wenn ich dieses Produkt kaufe, habe ich es ja auch nur für zwei Tage und dann ist es ja auch okay, wenn es danach wieder weg ist. Aber das ist halt, ich miete was und dann ist es mir egal, wie es aussieht, weil danach ist es wieder weg. Aber wenn ich was kaufe, bin ich ja der Meinung, es ist meins. Vielleicht nicht so, dass ich es weiterverkaufen kann oder zumindest nicht die Rechte da dran habe, aber es ist erst mal meins.
Ja, aber so könnte man ja dann sagen, dass irgendwie DRM ist ja eigentlich gar nicht so böse.
Für die Rente ist es, ja.
Ich finde bei DRM immer das Problem dieses Alles-oder-nichts-Prinzip, was es ja eigentlich ist. Also damit es überhaupt funktioniert, müssen mir Teile meines Betriebssystems und meines Rechners
vorenthalten werden, auf die ich quasi keine Kontrolle mehr habe.
Und damit ist damit Tür und Tor geöffnet für weitere Bösigkeiten.
Ja, und du kannst zum Beispiel nicht mehr zu Linux wechseln,
weil da kannst du deine Musik nicht mehr abspielen.
Das ist bei Rentals egal, weil die nächsten zwei Tage
weiss ich schon noch, ob ich da zu Linux wechsle oder nicht.
Kann ich auch gleich sagen, ob das so ist. Ja, beziehungsweise... Aber wenn du ein Mal unter Linux bist, kannst du nichts mehr ausleihen. Zum Beispiel. Ja, das ist natürlich auch dann immer noch beschränkt auf die Abspielplattform, die halt in dem Fall dann irgendwie Apple TV wäre oder eben iTunes. Naja, das ist eine knifflige Sache. Apple TV ist ja auch immer noch nicht so richtig losgedüst, ne, passiert ja nichts.
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, also ich glaube, in den USA sieht das jetzt schon anders aus,
aber ich habe noch keine Zahlen gehört.
Ich habe nur, was ich so wahrgenommen habe, ist, dass das jetzt gekauft wird.
Also vorher war es ja wirklich der amtliche Ladenhüter, und jetzt wird es schon ...
Verkauft. Aber das Angebot ist ja auch noch nicht besonders umfangreich. Hat eigentlich irgendjemand mitbekommen, dass man bei iTunes jetzt auch Fernsehserien kaufen kann? iTunes Deutschland meinst du? iTunes Deutschland, genau. Habe ich letztens festgestellt, weil da kam die dicke Werbeseite bei apple.de. Ah, genau. Da gehst du drauf. Der ganze schwarze deutschen Fernseh. Da bin ich, ne, ich gehe da nicht drauf. Ich bin da aber aussersehen mal drauf gelandet und dann ist sie mir entgegengeschlagen und da hat es mich ja doch verwundert. Es gab irgendwie ein, zwei Serien gab es am Anfang kostenlos zum Ausprobieren, die habe ich mir runtergeladen, habe sie mir aber bis heute nicht angeguckt. Ich hatte mir da was... Am Anfang nur jetzt nicht mehr. Ich weiss nicht, ob es das immer noch gibt. Also es gibt Desperate Housewives, Stromberg, South Park, Switch, Grey's Anatomy. Aber meines Wissens nach alles nur auf Deutsch? Das ist halt das Elend. Also du kannst zwar jetzt amerikanische Serien kaufen, ein paar, aber sie sind halt auf Deutsch. Ich meine, geht's noch? Und das finde ich ja auch an diesem Amazon MP3 doch ganz und gar furchtbar oder traurig, wo man ja eigentlich denkt, MP3 ist alles klar, die grosse Freiheit, aber ich in Deutschland kann das wieder alles nicht kaufen, weil virtuelle Grenzen existieren in den Köpfen der entsprechenden Musikanbieter und wahrscheinlich könnte man das irgendwie mal in Proxy machen oder sowas, aber warum kann ich nicht einfach auch amerikanische Musik hier direkt kaufen? Wegen der Aufteilung der Märkte weltweit. Das ist halt so. Es sind halt einfach mal andere Märkte mit anderen Margen und anderen Vertriebskonzepten und auch lizenzrechtlich ist das alles nicht so einfach.
Aber seien wir ehrlich, Pirate Bay kennt diese Aufteilung der Welt nicht?
Ja, das ist sicherlich richtig, aber so funktioniert das nun mal so. Also deswegen können die nicht mal eben da was machen. Wo sagst du die, diese kostenlosen... Ich weiss nicht, ob es die noch gibt. Also es gab die die ersten zwei, drei Tage auf jeden Fall. Achso, die wollen dich halt anfixen. Ja, ja, genau. Was habe ich mir, Ladyland habe ich mir runtergeladen und Pastewka. Ladyland? Was auch immer mit Anke, Enke, Enke. Ist es so, wie es sich anhört? Nee, nee, das ist so Comedy, glaube ich. Ich gucke ja kein Fernsehen mehr, ich weiß es nicht. Es ist ja, ich bin ja auch total raus, ich habe auch irgendwie auf diese Liste von Shows geguckt und dachte mir so... Ach, Pastewka ist schon lustig. Das habe ich ja noch nie gesehen. Das kann man sich schon geben. Was, was? Pastewka. Aber das ist alles so albernes Zeug und so Polizeiserien, ne? Hier so GSG9. Du hast auch kein Fernseher, stimmt's? Nee. Ja. Also, ja, da steht einer rum, aber der wird nicht als solcher benutzt, sondern das ist nur so Monitor für meine V. Vibesbilder. Super Mario Brothers gibt's jetzt für Dewey, Comedy, das ist dieser komische deutsche Mario Kart, Mario Kart meine ich ja, Mario Kart ist der Hammer, das habe ich mir gekauft, das ist ein kleines Lenkrad dabei, das ist so großartig, ich habe ihn schon gekauft, nein, dem Switch, ich habe es geschafft, ich habe es wieder gekauft, ja, und, das ist grossartig, das ist grossartig, ja, es macht tierischen Spass, ich habe sogar mitgebracht verdammt weil ich direkt aus dem büro und man kann mit den alten controllers spielen welchen alten mit den originalen mit dem von der nintendo 64 ja wie heißt der folge vom gamecube mit dem gamecube das ding was wir im club haben jedenfalls du da nicht anschliessen. Aber das war doch in der Werbung. Also die Gamecube-Controller gehen wohl mit. In welcher Werbung war das? Na, von Mario Kart für Wii. Da stand Nintendo 64-Controller. Nee, Gamecube. Ich glaube schon. Da stand Gamecube. Ich bin ja gar nicht so der Player, ich weiss nur, dass alle da total drauf abgehen. Ihr könnt ja mal kurz weiterquatschen, ich finde das raus. Nein, die Wii hat die Gamecube-Anschlüsse. Also du kannst Gamecube-Controller nehmen und kannst sie da direkt reinstecken.
Scheissegal, ob man da Gamecube-Controller oder was auch immer anschliessen kann.
Man hat so ein kleines Lenkrad dabei, da packt man diese V-Mode rein und dann kann man da lustig mit dem Kreis fahren.
Das ist grossartig. Ich habe das mit einem Kumpel gemacht, wir haben uns, also ist leider nur ein Lenkrad dabei
und Nintendo, mal wieder schön bescheuert, verkauft diese blöden Plaste-Lenkräder nicht für 15 Euro dazu,
sondern ich glaube, die gibt es noch gar nicht als Zubehör, nur ohne Spiel diese Lenkräder zu kaufen. Echt nicht? Ich habe sie jedenfalls nicht im Laden gefunden. Aber ansonsten ist das unglaublich. Wir haben uns betrunken und haben dazu Mario Kart gespielt. Was, ihr seid betrunken Auto gefahren? Wir sind betrunken Auto gefahren gegen Franzosen, die, glaube ich, alle ganz furchtbar sauer waren, weil wir 30 Sekunden länger gebraucht haben, um fertig zu werden, als die, beziehungsweise wir nie fertig gewonnen. Aber es ist ein ganz grossartiges Spiel, es macht tierischen Spaß, es ist noch ein Grund mehr, sich so eine Wii zu kaufen. Mobile Nintendo. Mobile Nintendo. Ja, naja, gut, also die Wii hat mich ja auch ergriffen, aber wer da ausführliche, ausufernde Informationen zu haben will, da kann man ja immer an unsere Podcast-Kollegen Games und so verweisen, die haben das irgendwie auch ausführlich getestet und eine Stunde lang wirklich über jeden Sprite referiert, der in diesem Spiel zu sehen ist.
Sollte ich vielleicht noch mal anhören.
Ja. Sag mal, du hast ja doch auch so ein mobiles Gerät gekauft.
Ich habe ja auch ein mobiles Gerät gekauft. Genau, das ist das. Das war ja gerade Republika. Und auf der Republika sind alle komplett durch... Republika war grossartig, wie ich fand. Du fandst ja auch ganz schick, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe. Ich habe mich positiv geäussert in meinem Blog. Immerhin, was von dir nicht allzu oft... Also ich meine, das ist schon ein grosses Lob, wenn du dich positiv... Ich habe mich auf der letzten Republika positiv geäussert. Ich muss aber sagen, dass ich dieses Jahr nicht so viel da war.
Also ich hatte, das ist schon ein grosses Lob, wenn du dich positiv... Ich habe mich auch zur letzten Republika positiv beäussert. Ich muss aber sagen, dass ich dieses Jahr nicht so viel da war. Also ich hatte leider nicht so viel Zeit. Letztes Jahr war es ja quasi dauerhafter, wenn ich mich recht erinnere. Jaja, genau. Diesmal habe ich es nicht so ganz so viel Zeit opfern können. Dafür war ich ein bisschen voreingenommen, was Republika angeht, weil ich bin ja mit beteiligt an dem ganzen Ding. Ich habe ja die SMS-Wand da unter anderem gebastelt und so ein paar Kleinigkeiten im Umfeld. Und was man auf der Republika gesehen hat, waren entweder, waren das alles Macbooks oder diese kleinen weissen Asus-Ee-E-PCs. Wie, die sind weiss? Es gibt die in weiss, es gibt die in schwarz. Ach so, ich habe die bisher nur in schwarz gesehen. Jetzt sollten wir nochmal kurz erklären, was die Republika ist. Also Republika ist hier die, stimmt eigentlich die Tagline Blogger-Konferenz, das wird immer so gesagt, das ist blöd, ne? Es ist eigentlich blöd, aber es ist ja, doch, das ist so, ja, digitales Leben, Klassentreffen der, oder Klassenfahrt der deutschen Blogosphäre auf Twitter war. Ich kann ja mal so tun, als wenn ich keine Ahnung habe und von wo kommen denn die Leute alles, so berlinweit, deutschlandweit oder europaweit? Auf der Republika? Das ist so Deutschland komplett. Also deutschsprachiger? Deutschsprachiger Raum komplett. Und dies Jahr gab es so erste internationale Anflüge, aber eher durch die Referenten, die eingeladen wurden. Und die sind auch hauptsächlich sind dann die Vorträge noch in Deutsch oder? Ja, aber es gab halt einiges auch auf Englisch und das, soweit ich das beurteilen kann, war auch ganz gut nachgefragt. Also hier Bicycle Mark war da und der Typ von Alive in Bagdad und Parade Bay, die Jungs waren da, Peter war wieder da, genau. Und das hat auch ganz gut gepasst, finde ich. Also es war halt auch so dieser Citizen Journalism Aspekt kam halt da mit rein. Naja, was man halt aber auch sieht, ist die Verbreitung der Macs, ich weiss nicht, was so war die gefühlte Macintosh-Quote auf der Republika. Circa 98 Prozent würde ich mal schätzen. What? Also es sind natürlich weniger, aber es ist, ich würde sagen, mehr als die Hälfte. Es waren wirklich, es war die Standardausstattung an Macintoshes. Also das ist in der Blogging-Szene, die Leute, die einfach mobil unterwegs sind, das ist da einfach, das ist einfach, das hat Apple einfach komplett geohnt mittlerweile. Also es war wirklich so. Ich habe mich losgewundert, dass kein Air zu sehen war. Also ich habe zumindest keines gesehen. Hast du eines gesehen? Sascha Lobe hat garantiert seines dabei gehabt, aber der hat sich ja sofort eines gekauft, nachdem es draussen war. Das ist das optimale Blogging-Tablet. Das ist so richtig dieses, ich sitze auf der... Ja, ich meine, guck mal, genau für solche Leute ist das nämlich gemacht. Die sitzen auf so einer Konferenz und es gibt ja so Jet-Setter, die hopsen einfach wirklich nur von Event zu Event. Du willst da was auf deinem Schoss haben, das soll dich halt nicht zu sehr erhitzen und nicht zu sehr beschweren, aber du brauchst diese ganzen Schnittstellen nicht. Du willst eigentlich nur WLAN, Tastatur und Bildschirm in OK und Akku hält lange. Und du bist die ganze Zeit am Rumrennen und hast eigentlich immer viel zu viel bei dir und bist froh, wenn es leichter ist und wenn du nicht eine grosse Tasche dabei hast. Genau, und dann machst du ein Kilo mehr oder weniger echt eine Menge aus. Und das war der Grund, weil ich... Davon habt ihr nicht viele gesehen. Nee, aber nun ist das ja auch noch relativ neu, muss man sagen. Die Leute werden jetzt nicht alle gleich ihre... Und relativ teuer, muss man ja auch mal sagen. Das stimmt. Das Bloggen ist ja für die meisten doch ein Hobby, und so ein Hobby, das darf ja nicht zu viel kosten. Aber um jetzt endlich den Bogen zu kriegen, was man dann eben doch gesehen hat, waren eben diese grösstenteils weissen, teilweise auch schwarzen Asus-EEE-PCs. Die einen unglaublichen Hype haben. Gibt es die schon in der neuen Version oder ist das noch die erste? Das ist noch die erste Version, die jetzt zur Zeit ist. Die kostet irgendwie 300 Euro. Könnt ihr nochmal kurz die Specs auflisten, so schnell aus dem Kopf? Und ich habe mir davon eins geholt. Ich kenne die Specs nicht genau, aber es ist so ein super kleiner Bildschirm, 8 Zoll oder so. Das ist ein knapp, ich glaube sogar 8 Zoll Display oder 7 Zoll Display, bin ich jetzt sicher, mit 800 x 480 Pixeln, also wirklich winzig klein. Es hat ein halbes Gigabyte RAM, glaube ich, 4 Gigabyte Flash-Speicher, es gibt auch eine Version mit 8 GB, aber die ist, glaube ich, quasi nicht zu bekommen. Da läuft standardmäßig ein Xandros Linux drauf und was hat es noch, ein SD-Karten-Flot. Und das war es im grossen Ganzen. Ach so, eine Kamera, Mikrofon, okayer Lautsprecher. Also man hat da ein Kleinst-PC mit irgendeinem... Kommt serienmässig mit Skype, muss man dazu sagen. Also es ist eigentlich schon ein ganz interessantes Gerät, wo man es sozusagen als Telefon benutzen kann. Das ist... Als Videotelefon. Und wir sind irgendwie durchgedreht und haben uns dann spontan diese Dinger gekauft, also
meine Wenigkeit, Jonny und Franzi, unsere Grafikerin von Spreeblick, und …
Aber warum? Also ich meine, was, wozu, was …
Das weiss ich ehrlich gesagt, also für mich weiss ich's auch noch nicht.
Also mehr so ein Spontankauf.
Es war ein Spontankauf. Wenn ich ins Café gehen will, also im Augenblick gehe ich ins Café zum Arbeiten oder eben nicht zum Arbeiten. Dann nehme ich den mit oder lasse ihn zu Hause. Aber das ist sowas, wo ich durchaus auch mal sagen könnte, den packt man in eine andere Tasche. Der ist auch klein, er ist leicht, er ist wirklich, würde ich sagen, ähnliches Gewicht wie knapp unter einem Kino, glaube ich. Aber da ist doch ein Linux drauf, richtig? Da ist ein Linux drauf. Und das ist alles so wie Linux. Das ist so wie Linux. Also ich hab mir jetzt...
Das heisst jetzt nichts. Das ist ja immer wertfrei, so wie Linux. Aber ich meine, kommst du dann damit klar? Fehlen nämlich deine Tools, weil du bist ja auch ein Meckenton. Nein, ein bisschen. Natürlich fehlt mir auch was. Das ist ja das genau, was ich mal ausprobieren wollte. Also ich habe mir jetzt das mitgelieferte Linux ist leider ziemlich einfach zu bedienen, aber ansonsten sehr, sehr scheisse. Es hat echt ein paar böse Macken. Also zum Beispiel, wenn man es aufklappt und aufwacht, dann verbindet es sich öfters mal nicht automatisch mit dem WLAN. Man muss die Zugangsdaten neu eingeben, also das Passwort für das WLAN, was natürlich ohne Ende ätzend ist. Das funktioniert alles viel besser, wenn man sich so ein, ich habe mir ja so ein Xubuntu draufgespielt. Das ist eine andere Variante von Ubuntu, die ein bisschen ressourcenschonender ist, und schon ist das Ganze richtig hübsch und dann habe ich mir einen Firefox 3 da draufgepackt und habe mir eben Skype, also Skype klar, Internettelefonie und Game, das ist so ein Instant Messenger dazugepackt, für Twitter habe ich mir Twitter Fox draufgespielt, das so eine Firefox-Erweiterung ist. Aber wir haben noch vorhin geredet, dass irgendwie die Macintosh-User, die auch so ein R haben, das sind ja auch Leute, die sich irgendwie nicht kümmern wollen. Die wollen doch nicht dann an so einem Linux rumbasteln. Die haben doch keine Zeit irgendwie dann auf der Blogger-Konferenz, geht die aus nicht, und dann müssen sie in die Tiefen der Command dann irgendwie abtauchen, um irgendwelche Sachen zu fixen. Aber ich hab Zeit doch für. Zum Basteln erst mal, ja. Tja, ich weiss nicht, also ich meine, wenn das eine halbwegs stabile Distribution ist, warum sollte das dann nicht... Unser Freund Frank hat sich auch ganz am Anfang so ein E-PC gekauft, hat irgendwie ein paar Wochen rumgefummelt und dann kam das eher raus und dann seitdem hat er einen Ehr. Also ich fand vor allem die Tastatur doof, also ich konnte da einfach gar nicht drauf tippen. Also die Tastatur ist extrem gewöhnungsbedürftig, wobei ich mich mittlerweile dran gewöhnt habe und okay drauf tippen kann. Nicht perfekt, aber ich kann ganz gut darauf tippen. Das ist schon ein echter Kompromiss, den man da eingeht, muss man sagen. Also ich habe den gesamten Artikel über den EEPC, auf dem EEPC geschrieben, und danach ging es. Seitdem kann ich echt okay darauf tippen. Man muss einmal ordentlich drauf bloggen, dann funktioniert das. Man muss einmal ordentlich drauf bloggen, dann geht es auch.
Ich würde niemals als einzigen Rechner verwenden, weil, also man kriegt auch deutlich mit, was die Einschränkungen von dem Teil sind. Der Trend geht zum Zweitlaptop. Der Trend geht zum Zweitlaptop und ich habe mir vorgenommen, wenn alle Stricke reissen und mir nichts mit einfällt, was ich mitmachen kann, dann kann ich ihn immer noch so als kleinen Homeserver nehmen, weil er hat einen relativ geringen Stromverbrauch. und schließe sich da eine externe USB-Festplatte an und dann läuft da alles so drauf, was man sich
wünscht, also SMB und BitTorrent und was nicht, sonst noch alles.
Und ja, aber bisher ist er mir eigentlich ehrlich gesagt zu schade. Also ich mag das Ding schon
ganz gerne, vielleicht auch gerade, weil er so eingeschränkt ist, weil man so, guckt mal, womit ich klarkomme. Aber es ist ein grossartiges, also ein kleines, hübsches Gerät, was man so, wie andere Leute sich Schuhe kaufen, glaube ich. Kann man sich auch mal so einen kleinen Laptop kaufen, das ist schon okay. Also ich weiss nicht, dieses IPC erscheint mir auf jeden Fall kein besonders konkurrenzfähiges Gerät zu sein. Oh, das ist auf jeden Fall. Also das war beeindruckend. Zu was denn? Wir sind mit den Dingern wieder zurückgekommen. Ich weiss auch nicht, jeder ist begeistert von dem Teil. Aber wie lange? Lang genug, um den Kaufprozess abzuschliessen, was erstmal das Wichtigste ist, glaube ich. Also ich glaube, es ist jeder der, also es sind, wir haben die dann bei Galeria Kaufhof oder sowas gekauft, da hatten sie noch welche durch Zufall oder hatten gerade frisch welche reinbekommen. Rechner kaufen bei Kaufhof. Macbooks kann man sehr gut bei Kaufhof kaufen, weil die haben eine Null-Prozent-Finanzierung im Gegensatz zu Graben. Ich glaube, die waren schon lange nicht mehr in Kaufhäusern. Das ist echt okay. Das ist, also ein Freund jetzt gerade gemacht, der hat sich sein Macbook gekauft mit Finanzierung und die haben so eine Null-Prozent-Finanzierung. Und ja, das ist dann deutlich günstiger, als wenn man das so mit Finanzierung kauft. Null Prozent ist null Prozent. Und Apple Care, das ist überall das Gleiche, der Rechner ist der gleiche und wenn er kaputt geht, dann schicke ich ihn ja sowieso zu Apple. Über was für einen Zeitraum kann man das da so strecken? Also ich kenne jetzt die genauen Konditionen nicht, aber das war schon wirklich so, okay, meinen nächsten Rechner will ich mir vielleicht auch da. Also nicht unbedingt hier zum Fachhändler. Ja, und die waren wirklich freundlich, hatten Ahnung und und das war, das war echt okay, und darum da eben auch den EEPC, und die, ich glaube, die hatten zwölf, die haben zwölf Stück bekommen, und ich glaube, die sind allesamt auf der Republika im Endeffekt in der Kalksteine wieder gelandet, weil wir sind damit angekommen und die Leute waren alle hin und weg.
Inklusive einer technikfeindlichen Frau wie meiner Tante, die wirklich augenblicklich losgezogen ist, um sich ein Ding zu kaufen. Und ich glaube, Frauen finden ihn alle toll, weil er so schön klein ist und das Nötigste abdeckt. Und er ist billig, klein und eigentlich doch, das ist eine ziemlich grossartige Sache, das wird definitiv ein fetter Markt werden. Ich glaube ja nicht, dass da viele sinnvolle Anwendungen sind. Wir können wieder eine Wette abschliessen. Ja, also ich meine, das Problem ist meiner Meinung nach einfach Linux. Also ich meine, was kommt denn da bitte für Anwendungen bei raus? Da haben Sie jetzt vielleicht so den Webbrowser und so ein bisschen so gestrickt, dass es drauf funktioniert, aber das war es dann wahrscheinlich im Wesentlichen auch. Gut, es gibt Skype, schön, wenn man im Wesentlichen im Websoft und Skype benutzt, dann ist es wahrscheinlich toll.
Genau.
Aber darüber hinaus...
Darüber hinaus brauchen die meisten Leute nichts.
Ja gut, also das ist dann halt einfach mal einen Webbrowser für 300 Euro. Aber da kann man ja auch gleich das iPhone nehmen, oder? Nee, es ist schon besser als ein iPhone. Aber es ist auch grösser als ein iPhone. Es ist auch grösser als ein iPhone natürlich, aber das ist also, es hat ja, es hat hat, also Tastatur ist definitiv deutlich besser als bei einem iPhone zum Beispiel, also man kann auch drauf tippen, man kann E-Mails drauf schreiben, auch verlimpft dich mit ein bisschen, wie gesagt, mit ein bisschen Gewöhnung, es hat so eine Banalität wie Copy and Paste, muss man ja auch, darf man ja auch nicht komplett vergessen, und außerdem ein iPhone ohne Rechner, ohne anderen Rechner wäre für mich unvorstellbar, also geht ja gar nicht.
Ja gut, das ist ja beim IPC auch, was wir schon festgestellt haben. Also der Trend geht zum Zweifel.
Also ich würde ihn nicht als Hauptrechner benutzen, aber ich kenne Leute, die würden das durchaus tun.
Ich glaube, man musste nochmal ein bisschen abwarten und dann...
Und dann werden wir das nochmal evaluieren.
Also ich finde, es ist ein spannendes Experiment, weil gerade auch Linux ist ja doch immer, ich finde es ja ein interessantes Betriebssystem und eben auch mal so ein, auch wenn die Hardware natürlich deutlich reduziert ist, aber auch mal so ein Gerät zu haben, auf dem ich das dann auch austesten kann, wie gut könnte ich mitarbeiten. Und es gibt eben ein paar Programme, die ich vom Mac wirklich sehr vermisse und wo ich sage, ah, das ist mein Mac um Klassenbesser, aber es sind ehrlich gesagt nicht so viele, wie ich mit gerechnet hätte. Okay, aber lassen Sie jetzt mal lieber über ZDF reden. Genau. Herzlich willkommen im Fernsehgarten. Hat aber jetzt aber dran gearbeitet. Ja, ich habe ja mal ZDF gesagt die ganze Zeit, das war jetzt auch weiter im ZDF. Aber eigentlich wollen wir über ZFS reden. Über ZFS reden. Weil du erinnerst dich, mit Leopard mit 10.5 ist ZFS auf den den Mac eingezogen, allerdings nicht so, wie wir uns das alle gewünscht haben.
Und ich kann ja einfach mal sagen, was ich zu dem Thema ZFS weiss und ihr und Dennis springt mich dann seitlich von der Seite an, wenn er es gar nicht mehr aushält und ihm ein Pulsader platzt. Nö, sag mal, also wir können es gleich mal vorwegnehmen, ich habe ja mit Dennis bei Chaos Radio Express einen sehr ausführlichen Podcast gemacht, CAE, was also sozusagen alles, was wir jetzt hier nicht erwähnen, das kann man dort sich nochmal machen.
Das ist aber weniger die Macintosh-Perspektive, sondern da geht es eigentlich wirklich so um ZFS als Fallsystem. Aber du kannst ja mal ein bisschen was du weisst.
Ich habe damals mitbekommen, dass das das neue, super gehypte Dateisystem ist, also das, womit man seine Festplatte formatiert, von Sun entwickelt worden ist und unglaubliche Dinge beherrschen wird und wahrscheinlich auch den Weltfrieden herstellen wird, die Hungerkatastrophen reduzieren und sowieso die Klimaerwärmung aufhält. Das ist alles, was ich mitbekommen habe. Und alle sind davon ausgegangen, ah, Apple wird das bestimmt als natives Dateisystem in Leopard einbauen und waren dann ganz, ganz furchtbar enttäuscht, als dass er nicht passiert ist. Das haben nicht alle gesagt, sondern das hat so ein Typ von Sun gesagt, der war wohl ein bisschen off-speed. Der Typ von Sun hieß, Jonathan Schwarz und ist der der Chef-CEO, genau. Ah, echt, der hat das gesagt? Okay, dann hätte ich es auch nicht geglaubt. Na, die fanden das wohl, die waren wohl so ein bisschen, also ich weiss auch nicht, was den getrieben hat. Die Geschichte, ja, also bis fertig oder was? Ja, und das ist eben zum Beispiel für Dinge wie Time Machine ganz hervorragend geeignet, wäre, weil man auch Versionierung auf Datei, eben, also man kann zwei Dateien, zwei Versionen einer Datei haben, ohne gleich die Datei doppelt auf der Festplatte ablegen zu müssen, dadurch einen guten Speicherplatz sparen. Solche Wunderdinge soll das Dateisystem wohl beherrschen. Aber das ist damit tatsächlich alles, was ich dazu weiss.
Ja, also im Prinzip stimmt das. Wir finden das ja toll, oder, Dennis?
Ich finde das total toll, aber ich muss auch sagen, es hat so ein bisschen, der Hype ist
so ein bisschen verschwunden gerade.
Das kann nur gut sein.
Wieso?
Wenn der Hype weg ist, fangen die Leute an, klar zu denken.
Ja, also es ist halt bei Apple seit, haben wir ja gerade vorhin geguckt, seit Januar gibt es irgendwie keine neuen Betas mehr. Also man muss erst mal, die Situation ist die. Nein, jetzt müssen wir erst mal nochmal kurz erzählen, was macht ZFS. Ich gebe dir mal so ein Management Summary. Also erstens, ZFS ist mehr als nur ein Dateisystem, es ist halt etwas, was eine vollständige Verwaltung von einen oder mehreren Festplatten macht. So, da gehört das Dateisystem dazu, aber es ist halt auch so viel, dass es eben so Sachen macht wie Raid.
Striping von Festplatten, also es ist auch sozusagen ein komplettes Rates-System mit drin, also dass du mehrere Festplatten gleichzeitig ansprechen kannst. Und das macht es eben, indem es Pools bildet. Also du kannst ein Z-Pool erschaffen, das ist sozusagen das Erste, was du tust, und in diesen Z-Pool wirfst du deine Platten rein. Da kannst du einfach diese Platte, diese Platte, was du auch irgendwie an deinem Rechner dran hast, wirfst du in diesen Pool und kannst du das einfach ansprechen, als wäre das eine grosse Platte. Die Schnittstellen sind dabei wurscht, oder? Ja. Du hast halt Block-Devices, also Festplatten oder einen USB-Stick oder was auch immer du hast und du addierst die in deinen ZFS-Pool dazu und du kannst halt sagen, ob du das als Mürre addiert haben möchtest oder ob du einen Stripe haben möchtest und das ZFS kümmert sich dann um alles. Und wie werden die Daten dann verteilt? Also kann ich dann problemlos noch diesen Memory-Stick wieder rausnehmen, ohne dass das alles kaputt geht? Zur Zeit geht es noch nicht, das heisst, wenn du bestimmte Devices in dein Pool geschmissen hast, dann müssen die da drin bleiben. Das soll aber irgendwann auch das Feature geben, dass man sagen kann, man will ein Device da wieder von weg haben, dass das sozusagen auf die anderen Devices rüberkopiert wird, dass das eine Device frei ist. Das gibt es aber noch nicht. Das gibt es noch nicht. Also gibt es noch nicht in ZFS generell? Oder gibt es nicht auf dem Mac? Gibt es noch nicht in ZFS. Aber das wollen die machen, ja. Das wollen die machen. Und läuft es auch über IP? Das wäre auch eine ganz spannende Frage. Ja. Es hat diesen Ice-Gazzy-Support. Hätte ich das jetzt richtig verstanden, aber ich habe selber aber noch nicht damit rumgespielt, deswegen kann ich da jetzt, müsste ich irgendwie auch aus dem... iSCSI ist SCSI-Over-IP, wenn ich mich recht erinnere. Ja. Also dass man sozusagen... Da gibt es Support für, aber es ist sozusagen... Davon weiss ich jetzt nichts. Es ist eher so ein Nebenfeature an ZFS dran, das ist ja nicht das eigentliche Feature. Ja, vielleicht nochmal so Feature-Set nochmal so kurz abrunden, also du hast diesen Pool, dann kannst du da drin halt deine File-Systeme erstellen und File-System erzeugen geht halt auf ZFS so wie auf anderen File-Systemen das Ordner erzeugen geht, also schnell. Genau. Ja, und dann kannst du halt einfach dir sozusagen deine eigene File-System-Welt machen, kannst auch sagen, irgendwie auf welche Platten sich das beziehen sollen und so weiter. Und diese ganzen Filesysteme, die du dort anlegst, sind dann eben auch hierarchisch. Was weiss ich, du hast ein Slash-Home-Filesystem und darunter hast du dann für jeden User auch nochmal ein eigenes Filesystem. Und jedes Filesystem kann aber seine eigenen Attribute haben, da kannst du dann so Sachen wie soll verschlüsselt sein, soll Kompression benutzen und so weiter mit reinschmeissen und vor allem vererbt sich das. Das heisst, was du für Slash Home definierst, das vererbt sich dann halt eben in alle Homes darunter und kannst auch nachträglich ändern und solche Sachen. Also extrem komfortabel. Und alles on the fly. Also du musst dafür nicht irgendwie unmounten und wieder mounten, sondern wenn du für ein Filesystem irgendwie eine Kombinierung einschaltest, dann machst du das, während der User eventuell sogar gerade seine Dateien da raufschiebt. Das wird einfach für alle Blöcke, die ab dann geschrieben werden, ist halt die Komprimierung dann an und für die anderen, die vorher geschrieben wurden, ist halt die Komprimierung noch aus. Und das funktioniert alles live. Und es ist ein 128-Bit-File-System, das heisst, es kommt auch mit verdammt grossen Platten zurecht, also wie der Entwickler da meinte, wenn man jetzt wirklich so ein 128-Bit-File-System mal wirklich füllen würde, dann müsste man dazu auch irgendwie die Ozeane zum Kochen bringen, weil einfach so die... Mit der Energie, die man dafür bräuchte, könnte man die Ozeane zum Kochen bringen. Mit anderen Worten, entweder wir kriegen es nie voll oder wir haben wirklich ein ganz schlimmes Wärmeproblem.
Zumindest gibt es keine Limitierung mehr mit irgendwie nur so und so viel Therabyte. Du brauchst einfach dir über Grössen von Fallsystemen keine Gedanken mehr machen. Du kannst da so viele Platten reindenken, reinwerfen bis du schwarz wirst. Und das war eben auch ein Ziel von ZFS, einfach diese Limitierung, die realistischen Limitierung einfach auszuschöpfen. Darum ja die Frage, funktioniert es auch über IP, weil damit könnte man ja alle Festplatten dieser Welt über das Internet zu einer gigantischen, grossen Festplatte zusammenschalten. Aber nochmal, ich gehe gerade mal darauf an, jetzt noch andere zwei, drei Features, die vielleicht noch wichtig sind, also alle kann man jetzt eh nicht erwähnen, aber was ich wirklich noch sehr cool finde, ist, es handelt sich um ein atomares Fallsystem, das heisst, jede Operation ist atomar, sprich, entweder sie wird durchgeführt, dann hast du den neuen Zustand, oder sie wird nicht durchgeführt, dann hast du den Zustand vorher. Das ist nicht so wie bei HFS, wo so ein Journal mitgeschrieben wird, also es wird nicht noch so eine Transaktionsliste nebenbei mitgeführt, sondern, wie doch? Das ist das Intention-Lock.
Das Intention-Lock? Ja. Ja, aber dass das nur für den nächsten Schritt ist, oder? Darf ich mal kurz? Das ist eigentlich das Gleiche wie das schon da. Nochmal für. Aber ich dachte, die Operationen selber sind atomar. Das schreibt erst in dem Moment. Also der hat beidesides, also sind atomar, weil jede Änderung, das ist ein bisschen kompliziert, aber er schreibt erst seine Änderungen und dann wird der Masterblock darüber sozusagen umgeswitcht und entweder er wurde umgeswitcht oder nicht, aber solange er noch
umgeswitcht, es wird auf den alten Content gezeigt und der wird nie gelöscht. Also es wird nie, wenn du eine Datei neu schreibst, dann wird nie oben drüber geschrieben, sondern es wird immer in einen anderen Bereich geschrieben und dann wird erst umgeswitcht. Und das hat für mich den Vorteil, wenn die Kiste, egal in welchem Zustand mir mein Rechner abschmiert. ZFS ist unkaputtbar, könnte man so sagen. Oder wenn ich einen Stromausfall habe, ist das immer alles. Aber was ist denn dann dieses Intention Lock? Das Intention Lock sorgt dafür, dass halt bestimmte Dinge, die halt zusammengehören, an einem Stück auch umgeswitcht werden. Ja, okay, das heisst der eigentliche, okay, verstehe, das heisst die, also atomar ist es insofern, als dass eben dieses, es wird immer eine funktionierende Struktur erstellt und der letzte Schritt ist, von dem alten auf das neue umschalten, aber damit auch dieser Schritt, dieser allerletzte, dieser eigentliche atomare Schritt auch wirklich technisch automat ist, gibt es für diesen kurzen Moment auch noch so ein Journal oder Intention Lock in dem Fall. Das ist aber ein technisches Detail. Das Schöne daran ist, dass diese Struktur vielfältig eingesetzt werden kann, nicht nur dafür, dass eben diese Konsistenz immer hergestellt wird, sondern auch zum Beispiel zum Erstellen von Snapshots. Du kannst also einfach sagen, der Zustand, in dem jetzt dieser ganze Pool, dieses Fallsystem ist, einfrieren. So, was weiss ich, du hast ein Skript und das macht einfach immer um Mitternacht sagt es, ich möchte jetzt gerne einen aktuellen Snapshot haben. Und dann kannst du, ab diesem Moment, wo du das sagst, ist der vollständige Inhalt deiner gesamten Platte, und zwar alles, ist erhalten, auch wenn in dem Moment weiter fleissig rumgeschrieben wird auf der Platte, weil du kannst dann nämlich in .zfs-Name dieses Snapshots einfach reingehen, sozusagen, hast da so ein virtuelles Directory und siehst da drunter einfach den alten Zustand.
Das heisst, was Time Machine jetzt noch jede Stunde auf eine externe Platte macht und mit Hardlinks löst, würde ZFS mit Snapshots lösen.
Genau. Und zwar on the fly, ohne dass irgendwie gross was gemacht werden muss, macht dann einfach Snapshots, das heisst einfach nur, dass mit der nächsten Änderung genau, dass er sich einfach diesen Zustand merkt und nicht wegwirft, sozusagen. Das heisst also, wenn ich das jede Stunde mache oder sowas, dann könnte ich immer auf die Datei von vor zwei Stunden zugreifen, ohne dass mein Rechner irgendwie grossen Mehraufwand hätte an Arbeit. Time Machine ohne Backup-Platte ist das sozusagen. Du hast es einfach auf deiner Platte, kannst du einfach den ganzen Zustand machen. Und das ist eigentlich so genau das, wo man denken würde, naja, also wenn sie schon mit Time Machine kommen, warum setzen sie nicht von Anfang an auf ZFS? Aber naja, so ist es nicht. Sie haben ja jetzt eine andere Lösung gefunden, weil es ja auch klar ist, dass sie nicht hätten auf ZFS wechseln können, weil dafür ist ZFS einfach noch zu neu. Das ist jetzt seit anderthalb Jahren gerade mal so fertig und auch, haben wir ja eben schon gehört, manche Features sind noch nicht wirklich zu Ende, also man kann auch noch nicht davon booten und so weiter. Krypto geht auch noch nicht. Krypto geht auch noch nicht, also es gibt so, so viele Sachen sind so im Prinzip vorgesehen, aber haben noch nicht so richtig das Licht des Tages gesehen. Das heisst, wir müssen damit wahrscheinlich noch bis Mac OS 10, 6 warten. Ja, ich meine, ich habe da sowieso nicht mitgerechnet, dass sie gleich, also mit einem neuen Betrieb, ich meine, da wären sie schön doof, ein vollkommen neues File-System, was noch überhaupt nicht getestet ist, von heute auf morgen zum Default-File-System zu machen, das ist Quatsch. Das haben sie ja mit HFS Plus auch nicht so gemacht. Mit HFS Plus, da kann ich mich ehrlich gesagt nicht mehr daran erinnern. Ja, das war so der 8.6 war das, oder? 8.1. 8.1, genau. Mit 8.1 haben sie es sozusagen erst mal erschaffen, dann gab es das. Aber Default war halt noch HFS. Und ich glaube, mit 8.6 war dann der Switch irgendwie so weit, dass es dann... Hat auf jeden Fall auch ein paar Jahre gedauert. Genau, oder mit 9.0 war, glaube ich, HFS Plus dann auch Default. Ich weiss, das ist mir auch nicht so wichtig. So, mit ZFS wird es sicherlich einen ähnlichen Weg gehen. Sie sind aber noch konservativer rangegangen und obwohl ZFS jetzt in Mac OS X 10.5 drin ist, ist es halt nur Read-only. Das heisst, du kannst nur fertige ZFS-Volumes, von denen man ja normalerweise gar keine hat, kannst du halt lesen. Mit anderen Worten, man kann eigentlich mit dem ZFS unter 10.5 noch gar nichts machen. Sie zeigen guten Wehen. Na, man kann halt bei macOS Forge sich eine Beta-Version, weil es ja eine Kernel-Extension, kann man sich runterladen, die auch schreiben kann, die ist auch ein bisschen neuer. Und mit der könnte man rumexperimentieren, würde ich halt erst mal nur für externe Platten empfehlen. Ja, sollte man auf jeden Fall nicht mit seinem Default machen, aber dafür ist es halt cool, weil du kannst eben ein paar Sachen machen, die sind einfach geil.
Jetzt wollte ich nochmal darauf zurückkommen, weil du meintest, wie ist denn das mit über
IP, also ein Teil von ZFS, es gibt da auch so eine fertige, es kommt da so mit Admin-Utility,
also die ganze Command-Line sozusagen ist mit dem ZFS mitdefiniert.
Also wenn du ZFS hast, dann hast du halt auch dieses Tool dafür, was einen sehr logischen
Aufbau hat.
Also zu ZFS gehört quasi ein kleines Admin-Programm dazu, sage ich das jetzt richtig?
Zwei?
Das eine heisst Zpool und das andere heisst ZFS. Mit dem einen verwaltest du deinen Pool,
deinen gesamten, und mit dem ZFS verwaltet man die File-Systems, die man innerhalb des
Pools hat.
Also die Frage, was habe ich davon, wenn ich mir das runterlade und mal auf einer externen Platte installiere, beantwortest du relativ einfach, starte ZFS und guck dir an, was es da für Befehle gibt und was ich damit machen kann. Genau, und eine Sache, die ich am wichtigsten finde, muss ich nochmal betonen, ist, dass alle Blöcke in ZFS haben immer einen Hash, das heisst, du kannst immer beweisen, ob der Block noch okay ist oder nicht, weil du kennst ja bestimmt den Fall, du hast so eine Platte, sagen wir mal IBM, die auch immer so schön klingeln, wo zwar draufsteht, dass es normal ist, aber man traut der Sache ja doch nicht so und man weiss nicht, geht die nun oder geht die nicht. Und ich hatte auch immer eine Platte, die hat auch komisch geklingelt und ich habe ja nie so richtig getraut. Ich habe sie zwar aber noch benutzt, aber auch nur so, um so billigen Scheiss irgendwie oder Filmchen irgendwie abzuspeichern. Da habe ich mal ZFS drauf gemacht und das ZFS hat sich nie beschwert und ich weiss, die Platte ist einfach nicht kaputt. Also da sind alle Blöcke okay, weil ZFS würde das halt sofort merken. Und wenn man dann ZFS auch noch in einem Mirror Mode benutzt, das heisst, du benutzt zwei Platten, kann, wenn eine Platte kaputt ist, kann ZFS durch den Hash auch immer feststellen, dass der eine Block nicht okay ist und kopiert dann den von der anderen Platte gleich rüber. Also kann Self-Repairing ausnutzen. Das ist überhaupt eines der cooleren Features. Also mit dem Hash, das heisst sozusagen, es gibt immer eine Checksumme für alles. Schreibt einen Blog, schreibt eine Checksumme und wenn er den dann liest, dann sieht er, oh, ist ja falsch. Wenn du halt Mirroring hast, wo du alles doppelt hast, dann kann er gleich auf der anderen Platte nachgucken, ist das Backup sozusagen in Ordnung? Wo bisher nur bekannt war, irgendwas auf dem Arsch? Genau, er konnte bisher beim Mirroring nur dann irgendwas feststellen, wenn halt richtige Fehlermeldungen von der Platte kamen, also wenn es sozusagen schon so richtig zu spät war. Meistens ist es ja so, zehn Versuche oder beim nächsten Mal und wenn draußen die Luftfeuchtigkeit anders ist, dann geht es dann irgendwie wieder. Aber so merkt er unter Umständen gar nicht, dass er was Falsches gelesen hat. Da kippt halt irgendwie so ein Bit und dann ist es irgendwie falsch.
So, und das kann ja halt mit ZFS nicht passieren. Und was ich noch am coolsten finde, das ist, dass sowas wie Incremental Backup auch Teil des Dateisystems ist. Also direkt Time Machine ist sozusagen auch von vornherein vorgesehen. Genau, das heisst, wenn du, also mein Traum-Setup wäre ZFS auf meinem Laptop, dann ein ZFS auf meinem Homeserver, wo sozusagen die eigentliche Backup-Platte ist. Und dann kannst du halt das so machen, dass du wirklich jederzeit, also du machst einen Snapshot und dann jetzt wirklich so jede Stunde, so wie Time Machine das macht, du kannst auch alle zehn Minuten machen, weil das kostet keine Zeit sozusagen, muss auch nicht wie jetzt bei Time Machine dann erstmal so ein Change-Log durchgehen, um zu gucken, was hat sich denn geändert seitdem, sondern er muss das einfach gar nicht machen, er geht einfach in den letzten Snapshot rein und da hat er dann den View, so wie es beim letzten Mal war und und kann in Seelenruhe halt auch wegbackupen.
Was mir nämlich auch noch nicht klar ist, also und dann geht das Incremental halt,
kannst du einfach über SSH rüberpipen und dann wird einfach das Incremental-Backup auf den Server per SSH gemacht. Das ist einfach Standard, da brauchst du nichts weiter zu installieren, das geht einfach so out of the box.
Das wäre natürlich sozusagen Time Machine ohne Time Machine und funktioniert sogar besser, weil was mir nämlich nicht klar ist bei Time Machine derzeit ist, was passiert eigentlich, wenn mein File-System unter Last ist, also die ganze Zeit verändert wird, während er ein Backup macht. Das würde mich auch mal interessieren. Weil er kann eigentlich, er hält ja nichts doppelt, er hat ja keine Snapshots in HFS+, er kann ja eigentlich gar nicht verhind, also er kann eigentlich immer alles nur so wegschreiben, wie es gerade in dem Moment ist. Also das heisst, führt denn ZFS auch, also ich weiss, dass das in Mac OS 10.5, was für Time Machine notwendig ist, muss ja überhaupt erstmal mitgelockt werden, was du gerade schon erwähnt hast, welche Dateien denn überhaupt verändert worden sind und wo denn Dateien neu angelegt worden sind. Und das macht ja eine Kernel-Extension in 10.5. Das macht... Oder der Kernel selbst sogar. Genau, der Kernel selber. Die FS-Events. Genau, das ist nämlich dieses neue Framework, die FS-Events. Ich nehme an, so wie das alles klingt, löst ZFS auch dieses Problem super elegant direkt im Dateisystem mit drin, dass dieses Nook sowieso irgendwo mit rumliegt. Nee, das FS-Events ist eine Stufe höher. Das braucht es gar nicht. Also diese Snapshots von ZFS machen das vollkommen überflüssig, dass du dir die Änderung merkst, weil du hast sozusagen einen Pfad zu der alten Version und einen Pfad zu... Na doch, für Spotlight-Indizierung und sowas ist das ja schon ganz interessant. Ne. Also hat es nicht drin oder ist es nicht interessant? Das Snapshot ist ja auf Blog-Ebene und nicht auf File-Ebene. Also was er meint ist, man braucht die Events noch für Spotlight, das stimmt. Ja, das stimmt. Aber da geht ja eins drüber. Genau, aber für dieses, was hat sich verändert seit, dafür bräuchtest du die FS-Events nicht mehr. Die brauchst du nur, wenn du sowas Dummes wie HFS Plus verwendest. Nein, oder wenn du das, was sich verändert hat, seitdem backuppen willst.
Nein, nicht, weil du gehst einfach ins letzte Snapstart und sagst, einfach dem ZFS backuppet das, was sich verändert hat, seit so. Und da brauchst du dann überhaupt nicht mehr zu gucken. Bei Time Machine funktioniert es ja derzeit
so. Das Betriebssystem hält ein Log vor für jedes Fallsystem. Also für jedes einzelne Daseilsystem wird ein Log geschrieben, und zwar schreibt er nicht, welche Dateien sich geändert haben, sondern welche Verzeichnisse sich geändert haben. Ich glaube, die haben den selben Artikel gelesen. Das kann gut sein. Das war der bei Ars Technica, der das sehr ausführlich mal dargestellt hat, was auch ein sehr kluger Ansatz ist. In Anbetracht der Tatsache, dass die Hardlinks bei HFS Plus ja auch Directories können,
im Gegensatz zu Standardlinux, wo es eigentlich nur mit Dateien geht,
passt das auch wie alles auch ganz gut zusammen.
Deswegen kommen da sehr ökonomische Suchanfragen raus und sehr ökonomische Backups auch.
Damit die Datenmenge nicht zu gross wird, an dem was weggeschrieben werden muss,
wenn ich mich nicht recht erinnere.
Genau, weil wenn sich nichts geändert hat, braucht Time Machine eigentlich nur einen einzigen Link zu machen.
Vielen Dank. Damit die Datenmenge nicht zu gross wird an dem, was weggeschrieben werden muss, wenn ich mich nicht recht erinnere. Genau, weil wenn sich nichts geändert hat, braucht Time Machine eigentlich nur einen einzigen Link zu machen. Die oberste Directory hat sich nicht geändert, zack, fertig ist das Backup. Aber das festzustellen dauert erschreckenderweise immer eine halbe Stunde ungefähr. Oder ein bisschen länger. Auch die Anzahl deiner Ordner anwescheinend. Es kommt halt darauf an, wie viel sich geändert hat. Also wenn du wirklich viele kleine Dateien hast, was weiss ich, wenn da so ein vier Gigabyte E-Mail-Folder, wo permanent irgendwie in jeden Folder eine Mail reinkommt und so, dann muss er halt länger suchen. Aber ich finde, das geht immer noch relativ schnell. Also mein letztes Backup-System, was Hardlinks verwendet hat, musste alles traversieren und dann dauerte irgendwann das Traversieren länger als mein Backup-Intervall und das war 24 Stunden. Wow, okay, das waren aber auch viele Dateien. Ja, ich meine, wie viele Dateien hast du auf deinem Computer? Das sind mittlerweile wahrscheinlich einige hunderttausend bis Millionen. Das sind ja mehr als man denkt. Da hast du schon Xcode installiert, da hast du schon mit dem Xcode alleine hunderttausend. Mir ist irgendwann mal aufgefallen, es ist ja mit HFS, ohne Plus war es ja nicht möglich, mehr als 32.000 Dateien auf einer Platte abzulegen, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Da gab es irgend so ein Limit, ja. Das ist doch seitdem, wo wären wir ohne HFS Plus? Weil seit FS vielleicht. HFS Plus ist nicht so schlimm wie HFS, aber es hat ein paar coole Features,, so alias und das mit den Directory-Hardlings.
Aber wenig Sicherheits-Support. Ja, und das ist nicht wirklich moderne. Also wenn da ein Bit gibt, dann weisst du nicht, ob es gekippt ist oder nicht. Das ist der sogenannte Silent Arrow und eigentlich müsste da jeder ganz schön doll Angst vor haben, weil du weisst nie, ob jetzt noch irgendwas geht oder nicht. Und wenn du zum Beispiel ein Krypto-Image hast auf deinem Rechner, da reicht wahrscheinlich schon ein Bit, dass du es nicht mehr öffnen kannst, wenn es an der richtigen Stelle ist. Okay. Oder ich meine, stell dir vor, irgendwelche wichtigen Daten so, du hast irgendwie für, ja, ich weiss wahrscheinlich jetzt voll nicht unser Bereich, aber so Dosierung von Medikamenten oder so, du hast die Datei für deine Oma, wie viele Pillen sie am Tag rein muss, was weiss ich, und genau an der Stelle kippt ein Bit und anstatt eine Eins steht da auf immer eine, weiss schon. Und plötzlich gebe ich der Oma mal drei Tonnen Pillen pro Tag. Ja, ist jetzt ein bisschen an den Haaren herbeigezogen, aber da kann sich ja jeder sein eigenes Szenario noch einfallen lassen. Aber du würdest es halt nicht mitkriegen, das ist das Problem. Weisst du, mir wäre lieber, wenn er sagt, es ist kaputt und du darfst dich nicht mehr verlassen auf die Datei und dann kann ich sie mir woanders besorgen. Also dieses klassische Vertrauen ist gut, Kontrolle ist besser, Prinzip. Genau, und ZFS ist immer mit Kontrolle. Man kann sie zwar abschalten, aber sie ist per Default erstmal grundsätzlich an. Das klingt für mich ein bisschen, warum haben wir das noch nicht? Genau. Because it's not ready yet. Und ich muss noch eine Sache kurz sagen bei den Snapshots, ja, und im Vergleich zu Time Machine. Time Machine kann halt diese Hardlinks auf File-Ebene machen. Das heisst, wenn du ein Movie hast oder irgendwie eine 1-Gigabyte-Datei und du änderst die, dann musst du halt die kompletten 1-Gigabyte irgendwie wieder umschreiben. Aber angenommen, du hast mit QuickTime nur den Titel von dem Movie geändert und der schreibt das irgendwie hinten irgendwie in die Metadaten rein, dann würde bei ZFS würde nur sich der Block ändern, wo halt der Titel sich geändert hat. Das heisst, der würde von einem 1-Gigabyte-Pfeil vielleicht so einen ZFS-Block schreiben, so 128 Kilobyte. Genau, das heisst also, die nächste Betriebssystem-Generation, wenn ich da irgendwie meine Photoshop-Datei ändere und eine Änderung drin habe, die ich nicht haben wollte, dann habe ich hoffentlich die Möglichkeit, einfach zu sagen, hey, dann gehe ich doch zur letzten Version zurück und drehe doch mal die Zeit zurück. Zum Beispiel. Genau, also eigentlich, wenn Apple wirklich konsequent ist, wenn sie wirklich richtig cool sind, was ja immer die grosse Frage ist,chmal sind sie es einfach nicht, aber manchmal, finde ich, machen sie einfach Bold Moves, so. Und der Bold Move in dem Bereich wäre, dass sie sozusagen sagen, okay, Time Machine 1.0, das war jetzt so ein bisschen das Legacy Time Machine, ja, wir versuchen jetzt auch noch mit alten File-Systemen und mit dem aktuellen Ist-Zustand klarzukommen. Und jetzt gehen wir irgendwie in die Gold Edition über.
Wir verwenden ZFS auf diesem Dateisystem. Und mich würde
es übrigens nicht wundern, wenn wir mit irgendeinem
10, 5, 8
auch Writable ZFS
eingeschaltet bekommen. Ja, ich denke auch, dass
es noch kommen wird. Es kommt noch in 10, 5,
da bin ich mir eigentlich sogar relativ sicher.
Weil sonst könnten sie sich da nicht so sicher sein,
dass mit 10, 6 das dann auch wirklich funktioniert.
So, also bold move wäre, wir gehen jetzt default auf ZFS, es könnte sogar sein, wir requiren ZFS, wir müssen, ja, you never know, guck mal mal, ich sage bold move.
Wäre das, könnte auch optional sein, so nach dem Motto, du kannst dich beim Installieren entscheiden, willst du jetzt ZFS machen oder willst du HFS Plus machen. Und wenn du ZFS machst, dann hast du Time Machine Gold Edition und da hast du genau diesen Features, die wir jetzt im Prinzip so als Features von ZFS runtergebetet haben. Aber genau darauf komme ich. Snapshots, das heisst dieses Ganze, du kommst eine Stunde zurück ohne Backup-Platte.
Also du hast sozusagen dieses Feature mit Ich ich gehe zurück, einfach auch, wenn du offline mit deinem Laptop durch die Gegend rennst. Das vermisse ich ja sowieso ein bisschen. Wir arbeiten noch eh Apple, wir arbeiten noch eh alle immer auf Laptops. Wir haben keine Backup-Platten dabei. Macht das so, macht Time Machine so, dass es auch ohne Backup-Platte funktioniert. Ja, aber das gibt einfach das Dateisystem nicht her. Aber mit ZFS wäre das überhaupt gar keine Arbeit. Also sie müssten nichts anderes machen als ZFS-Snapshot-Name sowieso einmal auf der Commandline aufzurufen und dann hast du das. Aber da gehe ich davon aus, dass sie das tatsächlich tun werden, weil das haben sie ja auch mit Spotlight, war es ja ganz ähnlich, da war es ja auch in 10.4 kam die erste, 10.4 kam die erste Version von Spotlight, die ja auch eher so und mal oben drauf gesetzt und jetzt mit 10.5 ist es wirklich schön tief. Jetzt funktioniert das. Mit FS-Events richtig schön tief im Betriebssystem eingelassen und. Das war es auch schon vorher. Tatsächlich benutzt Spotlight nicht FS-Events, sondern Spotlight benutzt die eigentlichen Kernel-Events. Das heisst, Spotlight kriegt... Weiterhin, ich dachte, das hätten Sie in einer vorherigen Version gemacht. Nein, weil Spotlight ist ja schnell genug, um das zu machen. FS-Events steht ja allen zur Verfügung. Das ist ja ein offenes Ding. Und wenn sich jetzt jedes Tool auf diese Kernel-Event-Ebene mit ich konsumiereiere jede Änderung, dann läuft halt sehr schnell überhaupt nichts mehr. Es gibt ja dieses schöne Tool, kennst du vielleicht auch, FS-Eventer. Das habe ich sogar drauf. Das ist extrem geil, kann man auch irgendwie jedem nur empfehlen, wenn man so ein bisschen ein Gefühl dafür bekommen will, wie das funktioniert mit diesen File-System-Events. FS-Eventer klingt sich halt da ein und zeigt einem einfach wirklich jede Änderung grafisch an, aber das ist natürlich auch ein echter CPU-Fresser, wenn viel los ist auf der Platte, weil er im Prinzip jeder Änderung hinterher springen muss. Aber man sieht sehr schön, wie unglaublich viele Dateien sich bei jeder Kleinigkeit mittlerweile ändern. Jo, jede Preference-Datei geht erst mal auf und wieder zu. Ja, man findet auch schnell so die Datei, die das Programm schreibt, nachdem man die Seriennummer eingegeben hat und so. Das ist sehr praktisch. Die letzte Sache noch hier zu der Vision mit Time Machine Gold Edition. Also erstens, man hätte sozusagen die Zeitmaschine auch auf der Platte ohne Backup-Platte, was schon mal so schlecht nicht wäre, und man hätte wahrscheinlich auch viel, viel, viel schnellere und vor allem viel, viel, viel kleinere Backups. Also das, was Dennis gerade gesagt hat, mit Blocklevel versus Filelevel, also Leute, die heute mit grossen Dateien arbeiten, Video, ja, Photoshop irgendwie im Masterformat, keine Ahnung hier, Fotos, Fotobearbeitung, Aperture, Tralala, dieser ganze Kram, wo einfach innerhalb von einer Stunde Arbeit mehrere Gigabyte an, ja, an neuen Dateien quasi anfallen. Oder zumindest geänderten Dateien. Ja genau, also Dateien, die in ihrer Summe der Grösse mehrere Gigabyte umfassen, aber eigentlich nur haben sich vielleicht zwei Megabyte geändert. So und das wäre halt bei Time Machine heute mehrere Gigabyte, die dann immer wieder komplett auch übertragen werden müssen, wenn es über WLAN geht. Ich kenne das zum Beispiel von Vmware, wo das natürlich dann passiert, oder Paragon, wo man diese Festplatte hat, diese virtuelle und bam, wie jeder kleine Änderung. Und bei ZFS wäre es halt wirklich nur das, was sich geändert hat. Und das ist natürlich eine ganz andere Dimension, weil einfach dein Diff ist dann einfach viel kleiner, dann kannst du dir das leisten. ZFS ist tatsächlich nicht so weit weg von Welthunger, Weltfrieden her. Das ist wirklich mal eine echt gute Idee und Sun haut ja auch mächtig auf die Kacke, deswegen haben sie glaube ich auch so ein bisschen gehofft, dass Apple gleich da so in den Sprung geht. Warum der jetzt so schlecht informiert war, weiss ich nicht, weil das mussten die eigentlich gewusst haben, dass sie das nicht machen können. Ich habe gehört, dass der Jonathan Schwarz hier heißt, dass der sowieso nicht so der Allerschlauste sein soll. Ja, bei Sun, ich meine, die machen auch Java. Also das ist wie auch immer. ZFS ist auf jeden Fall, da muss man sagen, da liegt auch wirklich die ganze Kompetenz dieser Firma drin. Die machen seit Jahrzehnten, machen die Server, Filesysteme, irgendwie NFS, das kommt alles von zu sagen, das ist so deren Kernkompetenz. Und dieses Problem mit Speichern von Dateien, das haben die einfach verstanden, im Gegensatz zu vielen anderen. Ich meine, Microsoft ist kläglich gescheitert daran, ein neues Fallsystem zu machen mit ihrem Benefis. Oh ja, das ist, die haben es einfach die Komplexität und die Implikationen, die das auf ihr OS legt, irgendwie nicht in den Griff bekommen.
Und das bedeutet schon was, dass das ZFS da ist. Interessant finde ich noch, das ist ja diese CDDL-Lizenz, also diese Community Distribution-Tradition.
Tralala-Lizenz von Sun, die eher so eine BSD-artige Lizenz ist, so ähnlich wie auch die APSL von Apple, die schon als Open-Source-Lizenz gilt, aber die halt so mit Linux und mit GPL halt nicht klarkommt, weil GPL will immer nur mit GPL bumsen und deswegen gibt es das halt bei Linux nicht im Kern. Das ist natürlich auch ein Verbreitungshindernis in gewisser Hinsicht, weil eben da das nicht gemacht wird, aber mit BSD ist es kein Problem.
In FreeBSD7, stimmt's, ist FreeBSD 7 ist jetzt vor kurzem rausgekommen und da ist halt ZFS in full glory einfach default. Ist das dann das erste Betriebssystem, wo es dann so drin ist oder das erste nach Solaris und OpenSolaris? Bei Linux haben auch irgendwie ZFS on Fuse, das ist File System on Userland, aber, aber da weiss ich nicht genau wie weit die sind, aber die sind da wohl auch ganz normal vorne mit dabei, aber es ist halt limitiert durch diesen Fuse-Ansatz, das ist halt ein bisschen anders. Geht halt immer durch den User-Space und hat von daher nicht so die Performance, aber für so eine Backup-Platte ist es irgendwie völlig in Ordnung. Fuse ist ja sowieso auch so eine relativ spannende Sache, wie ich finde, auch Macfuse, aber da muss man jetzt nicht detailliert drauf eingehen. Kannst du da einen Link nochmal mit reinmachen. Genau, auf Macfusion insbesondere. Ja, also Fuse, ich meine, wenn wir jetzt eh gerade bei Fallsystemen sind, passt das ja noch ganz gut rein, dieses Macfuse. Also Macfuse ist ja ein, warte mal, jetzt komme ich mal wieder durcheinander, MacFuse ist die eigentliche Engine, genau, MacFusion ist ein Programm, MacFusion ist nämlich das Programm, was ein User-Interface darstellt für MacFuse.
Genau, das hat gar nichts damit zu tun.
Ja, das ist echt Con-Macfuse. Confusing. Aber ja, nochmal...
Also mit Macfuse, das Stand von Fuse, wenn ich alles richtig verstanden habe, ab, was für Linux sowas ist, dass man im Userland, Userland-Modus, Dateisysteme schreiben kann, entwickeln kann, die alle Funktionalitäten bieten. Das heisst, dass ich im schlimmsten Fall oder im besten Fall auch in Python oder in irgendwelchen Script-Sprachen oder in Java Dateisysteme plötzlich schreiben kann und das nicht mehr irgendwelchen Kernel-Hackern überlassen werden muss. Das ist ganz gut zum Prototypen und das ist auch gut für so Sachen, die sich eigentlich auf Kernel-Level auch überhaupt nicht integrieren lassen könnten. Wie zum Beispiel, wofür es ja sehr gerne genutzt wird, SFTP oder FDP oder ähnliche Sachen. Sowas zum Beispiel ist ein gutes Beispiel oder hier auch, also dieses Macfuse kommt ja von diesem Amit Singh, also dem Chef-Macintosh-Typen bei Google und dann fragt man sich natürlich, warum fördert Google das so und es gibt halt dann dafür, für Fuse gibt es auch Module, ich habe es noch nicht ausprobiert, aber es gibt es, um zum Beispiel auf Google Docs zuzugreifen. Das habe ich ausprobiert, das ist eine relativ hübsche Anwendung. Das ist eine coole Sache, weil du hast halt so ein virtuelles File-System, was nicht wirklich ein File-System ist, so ein Storage, ein Online-Storage von Dateien. Genau. Und so kannst du dann eben mit einem beliebigen Protokoll, in dem Fall werden es irgendwelche Webservice-Sachen sein, darauf zugreifen. Plötzlich geht irgendwie eine virtuelle Festplatte auf, für Picasa ist das sehr schön. Gibt es eigentlich auch schon Amazon S3 für Fuse? Das wäre doch eigentlich auch nochmal genau das Richtige. Wovon ich rede? Ja, ja, das ist der Fallsystem Storage von S3 ist von Amazon ein Fallsystemdienst. Da kannst du dir einfach hingehen und sagen, guten Tag, ich möchte gerne Slash Fuba haben. So, und Fuba darf aber noch nicht vergeben sein. Das kostet was? Das kostet sowohl, also es kostet, du zahlst für Speicherplatz und du zahlst für Traffic. Aber es ist halt viel billiger als vieles andere. Das ist jetzt eine ganz neue Geschichte, oder? Nee, so nah ist es nicht. Es ist nicht brandneu, aber es gehört so zu den neueren. Twitter basiert komplett darauf. Ein Jahr, das ist glaube ich alt. Ja, viele legen da so ihre Bilder ab und tralala. Als es neulich mal down war, hat man mitgekriegt, wie unglaublich viele Webseiten davon mittlerweile abhängig sind. Da war wirklich S3 down? Da war S3 down. Und es ging nichts mehr. Backpack ging nicht mehr, es ging Twitter ging nicht mehr, WordPress.com ging grösstenteils nicht mehr. Also es war unglaublich viel, was plötzlich nicht mehr ging. Also es sind sehr, sehr viele Dinge. Ja, weil die garantieren dir halt, dass die Daten gebackupt werden. Das ist natürlich schon mal was wert. Die garantieren auch vor allem eine brauchbare Bandbreite. Ich weiss nicht genau, was sie garantieren, aber Amazon hat halt einfach Wumm. Im Prinzip machen sie nichts anderes, als die Infrastruktur, die sie sowieso brauchen für ihre fetten Sachen, einfach nochmal unterzuvermieten und das eben über ein spezielles Protokoll. Aber die machen das halt so HTTP-Webzeln. Warum macht Google nicht sowas auch? Das ist eine gute Frage, ob sie das machen. Also G-Disc, das kommt ja irgendwie nicht aus dem Knick, das wird ja schon lange darüber spekuliert, dass das irgendwann mal kommen würde. Was sie jetzt haben, ist diese Google-App-Engine, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht. Ja, aber das ist ein Framework für Anwendungsentwicklung. Na, nicht nur ein Framework. Ach schon, aber sie hosten auch deine Programme, genau. Genau,
sondern es ist das quasi nicht Storage, sondern auch das Host der Programme dafür. Genau, also
mich würde es nicht wundern, wenn sie auch noch mal Storage machen, aber sie sind eigentlich
nicht so... Also mich würde es wundern, wenn sie es nicht tun, über kurz oder lang.
Tja, keine Ahnung, ob das hier ist.
Und das führt da für uns alle im Endeffekt zu einem, wenn es super funktioniert, zu einem Internet, wo Seiten nicht mehr plötzlich überlastet sind, bloss weil sie über Nacht populär geworden sind, im Idealfall, sondern wo die hoffentlich ein bisschen länger erreichbar sind. Ja, aber das führt aber auch dazu, dass... Abhängigkeit von einigen wenigen, natürlich. Da muss jeder für sich selber abwägen, aber ich meine, wenn du mal eben so, was weiss ich, wenn du mal eben für vier Wochen lang einen Gigabyte Webspace brauchst, weil du für irgendein doofes Projekt was machen musst, da gehst du doch nie los und klickst den Hoster und machst dir den ganzen Stress, wenn du auch mal eben im Webformular sagen kannst, gib mir mal Slash Tralala und lädst es dann einfach hoch. Das Problem ist, sie machen halt nicht irgendwie SFTP oder so, sondern man muss halt schon dieses S3-Protokoll sprechen. Das ist aber so auch in den populäreren File-Transfer-Clients mittlerweile drin. Also Transmit hat es schon drin und irgendein anderes hat es, glaube ich, gerade nachgerüstet. Genau, also diese ganzen typischen File-Transfer-Tools auf dem Mac können halt dieses S3-Dingsbums auch.
Und das ist, also ich habe bisher noch nicht den Anwendungsfall gehabt, aber gerade wenn man auch mal ein paar Filme, weil man bezahlt pro Gigabyte relativ wenig und man bezahlt pro Get-Request, das heisst also es lohnt sich für richtig grosse Dateien und wenn man mal irgendwie ein paar Filme hat und sicher will und die nicht unbedingt der eigenen Infrastruktur einfach trauen will, zum Beispiel jetzt für sowas wie Podcast, wenn die massenhaft gefragt werden werden, hat man halt mit S3 was in der Hinterhand, was zwar im S3 ein bisschen Geld kostet, aber einem nicht unterm Arsch wegbricht. Ich glaube, das ist schon eine ganz feine Sache eigentlich. Ja, also es gibt jetzt hier auch sowohl auf Code Google.com als auch auf S3 gibt es irgendwie S3-Fallsysteme für Views, also was ich vorhin vermutet hatte. Also Bucket heisst das nämlich bei S3 genau, da kannst du ein Bucket machen, also du hast keine Unterdirektoris, sondern du hast wirklich nur Slash Tralala und darunter deine Files, mehr ist es nicht, aber ja. Mit deinen Statistikseiten, wie viel irgendwie? Das kann ich jetzt, das weiss ich nicht so genau. Ich habe es selber noch nie genutzt, aber es muss. Aber es muss ja irgendwie so etwas geben, die machen ja eine Abrechnung. Aber viele Leute benutzen das. It's very popular. So. Jetzt sind wir von ZFS nach Fuse nach S3 gekommen. Ja, und jetzt haben wir, jetzt müssen wir uns mal überlegen, wie lange wir unseren Podcast gestalten wollen. Letztes Mal hatten wir ja den Piloten und haben uns 1,45 Uhr gegönnt. Jetzt sind wir aber eine anderthalb Stunde durch. Haben wir denn noch was auf der Liste? Wir könnten noch über 64 betreten. Na, ganz kurz. Geht ja schnell. Ganz kurz. Das ist, glaube ich, in dieser Runde hier der falsche Begriff. Naja. Okay, wir werden ja immer ermuntert. Also wir haben ja sehr viel nettes Feedback bekommen zu der ersten Sendung, da können wir uns auch schon nochmal ganz nebenbei mal führen. Das haben wir bisher noch gar nicht erwähnt, oder? Nein, haben wir bisher noch nicht erwähnt, müssen wir aber erwähnen, weil das war alles sehr nett und sehr ermutigend. Also wenn wir ja auch so Rede gewandt, sehr grossartig, genau. Und einer der Hinweise war, was ich aber auch sehr häufig höre, auch bei Chaos Radio Express, ist auch eigentlich egal, wie lange das Ding ist, man kann immer auf Pause oder Stop drücken, weil dann hältst du einfach noch mal länger und wir reden ja sowieso nur alle zwei Wochen. Da war ich relativ skeptisch, ob das von der Länge her, aber es scheint, alles scheint es so zu mögen. Na, wenn es sich für 64-Bit nicht interessiert, kann er jetzt einfach auf Stop drücken. Gebt doch nach Hause! Na, man kann es auch freundlicher sagen. Ja, unsere Hörer in der 32-Bit-Welt, da verabschieden wir uns jetzt schon mal In der Schweiz, in Österreich, in der 32-Bit-Land. Der Rest dieses Podcasts kann nur in 64-Bit empfangen werden. Genau. Drehmehrze-Kilobit-Rate hoch. Ja, der Anlass, warum 64-Bit hier auf unserer Liste steht, ist die Ankündigung von Adobe, die nächste Version von ihrer Creative Suite, nämlich die Nummer 4, unter anderem auch in einer 64-Bit-Version herauszubringen,
allerdings nur für Windows, nicht für den Mac, weil die Software, nein, diesmal liegt es nicht an Adobe, sondern es liegt einfach an Apple, Weil Apple hat vor zwei Jahren, naja, sie haben vor zwei Jahren Carbon 64 als Early, da gab es Talks auf der Developer-Konferenz und sie haben gesagt, dass sie an Carbon 64 arbeiten. Mit anderen Worten, auch Carbon-Anwendungen sollen irgendwann 64-Bit sein. Müssen wir doch erklären, was Carbon ist? Carbon ist das alte und Coco ist das neue Framework sozusagen für Applikationen auf dem Mac. Photoshop war schon mal Carbon, weil die halt ein bisschen hinterher waren. Deswegen haben sie auch damals schon so lange gebraucht. Das kommt von Mac OS 9. Da kann man ja keinen Vorwurf machen. Das wurde ja schon aber auch ein bisschen umgestrickt. Carbon ist ja nur noch der Restbestand von dem Mac OS 9. Da wurde eine Menge weggestrichen. Ja gut, aber sie haben Sachen weggestrichen, die wahrscheinlich Photoshop sowieso nie benutzt hat. Meinst du?
Naja, vielleicht ein paar Sachen, aber so viel war das ja nun ordentlich.
Also für Adobe war es auf jeden Fall eine clevere Sache, wahrscheinlich zu sagen, okay, wir machen das erstmal alles für die Umstellung von Mac OS 9 auf Mac OS 10, machen wir einen Carbon.
Aber dafür hat es ganz schön lange gedauert.
Ja, finde ich auch.
Und ich meine, jetzt haben Sie sich...
Gerade auch Adobe ja immer mit auf der Bühne ganz vorne dabei war, um zu erzählen, wie unglaublich schnell die Umstellung von allem auf alles ging. Also ich kann mich noch daran erinnern, dass der damalige Adobe-Chef bei der Vorstellung von Mac OS X auf der Bühne war, um zu erstellen, wie unglaublich schnell ein Entwicklerteam eine Photoshop-Version für Mac OS X rausgebracht hat. Da war irgendwas, ne? Und dann kam jahrelang nichts. Und dann dauerte es ewig und dann bei der Intel-Umstellung war genau das gleiche Problem, dass nämlich auch da wieder der Adobe-Chef auf der Bühne stand und sagte, unsere Entwickler haben innerhalb von 20 Sekunden die Komplett-Photoshop auf Intel umgestellt und dann hat es noch knapp anderthalb Jahre gedauert, bis tatsächlich die Intel-Version rauskam. Wie lange? Also sehr, sehr lang. 64-Bit-Version wird auch noch sehr lange dauern, aber diesmal haben sie es gleich zugegeben. Aber vielleicht noch mal kurz erzählen, was Apples Teil jetzt war.
Also Sie haben irgendwann mal gesagt, wir wollen auch Carbon64 machen. Ich weiss nicht genau, wie wacky Sie dabei waren, als Sie das angekündigt haben, aber es gab wohl, es gab Präsentationen auf der WWDC vor zwei Jahren. So, im letzten Jahr haben Sie angekündigt, wir werden Carbon64 nicht machen. Das heisst, man kann nicht eine Anwendung, die noch auf dem alten Carbon basiert, die aus der Mac OS 9 Zeit kommt, kann man eben nicht 64-bittig machen. Da hängt ja ein riesiger Rattenschwanz von Tralala dran, vor allem ist es eben die Aufgabe von Quickdraw, also das alte Grafikmodell stirbt sozusagen damit dann auch. Und wenn man also jetzt eine 64-Bit-Anwendung machen will, dann muss man auf Cocoa gehen.
Und das werden Sie halt jetzt notgedrungen tun. Dazu müssen sie aber ihr komplettes Framework, also ihr komplettes Application-Framework umstellen auf Cocoa. Und da würde es mich noch nicht mal wundern, wenn es noch bis CS6 dauert. Das wird bestimmt der ganze... Die werden sich bedanken. Erstmal die Umstellung auf Mac OS 10, die ja lange gedauert hat, dann die Umstellung auf Intel und jetzt noch der nächste Schritt, wo sie nochmal die Plattform quasi... Schon auch so ein bisschen der öffentliche Rosenkrieg, den wir da beobachten können, oder? Also ich meine, Adobe und Apple sind ja schon auch gewisse Konkurrenten im Lightroom-Aperture-Department. Das stimmt. Nicht nur da, auch im Premiere-Final-Cut-Pro-Department. Ja, schon der nächste siehst du. Wobei auch Final-Cut-Pro ist Carbon.
Das sieht man dem ja auch an. Oder iTunes. Oder iTunes. Bei iTunes riecht man es. iTunes wird aber auf lange Zeit noch keinen 64-Bit-Bedarf haben. Aber Coco-Bedarf. Wobei so viel Ram, wie das frisst, irgendwie. Nee, also bei iTunes bin ich ja mal sehr gespannt, weil jetzt so viel mehr, wie das mittlerweile macht. Ich meine diese ganze iPhone-Synchronisierung und Betriebssysteme nachinstallieren und sowas eigentlich. Die gesamte Kommunikation mit dem iPhone läuft darüber ab. Ja gut, aber 64-Bit, vielleicht sollte man das einfach nochmal kurz erwähnen, also wer braucht 64-Bit?
Das sind Programme, die gleichzeitig viel Speicher, also mehr als vier Gigabyte RAM adressieren müssen.
Oder die irgendeinen Benefit davon haben, dass sie es können.
Mehr als vier oder nicht mehr als drei? Nein, mehr als vier. Auf dem Mac ist es tatsächlich, kann eine Anwendung auch mit 32-Bit-4-Gigabyte-Ram adressieren. Das ist anders als bei Windows. Da ist die Limitierung bei drei und eins ist irgendwie für das Betriebssystem reserviert, aber macOS 10 hat eine andere Art und Weise, da hin und her zu schalten, deswegen gehen tatsächlich auch vier. Allerdings, ja, gibt es auch noch nicht so viele Rechner, die das haben, aber wir wissen alle, das ist absehbar, Mac Pros, die neuen kommen irgendwie schon, glaube ich, mit vier und man kann da halt 16 reinstecken und so weiter. Also alle Leute, die sich dieses Jahr ein Laptop gekauft haben, die ich so kenne, haben da vier Gigabyte drin. Außerdem ist es so, dass manche Operationen, und da gehören sicherlich auch einige dazu, die Photoshop nutzen würden, auf 64-Bit dann auch schneller laufen. Also manches ist tatsächlich auch schneller, da redet man nicht. Vieles aber auch langsamer, wenn man nicht alles täuscht. Das wage ich zu bezweifeln. Na, weil jeder Pointer, der vor 32-Bit gross ist, jetzt ja 64-Bit gross ist. Deswegen sind da Strukturen. Benutzt natürlich mehr Speicher gleichzeitig. Genau. Aber ich würde nicht sagen, dass es dadurch automatisch langsamer wird. Es belegt mehr RAM. Nö, was natürlich aber schon wieder schlecht für das Caching ist und so weiter und so fort. Das stimmt. Aber ich glaube, am Ende profitiert man mehr davon, dass bestimmte Operationen in einem 64-Bit-Modus dann auch schneller durchzuführen sind, insbesondere wenn es jetzt darum geht, so SSE-Kram, also so Vektorrechnungen. Und das ist natürlich gerade für sowas wie Photoshop, wo dann tausend Layer irgendwie immer wieder zusammengerechnet werden müssen, um ein Bild anzuzeigen, auch schon sinnvoll. Von daher ist es klar, die wollen da hin. Photoshop muss auch da hin. Ja, vor allem, es macht auch für Photoshop Sinn, ich meine, viele Leute sagen so, ah, naja, wieso, meine Bilder sind ja gar nicht so gross. Ja, aber bei 20 Layern schon.
Bei 20 Layern schon und vor allem auch noch, wenn man 100 Undo-Level im Speicher haben will.
Ich arbeite sehr viel mit Grafikern zusammen, die alle ein Lied davon sehen können, wie unglaublich viel Speicher so ein Bild benötigt und wie viel.
Also Arbeitsspeicher kann man nie genug haben als Grafiker.
Genau, und für Film ist es natürlich noch viel krasser, also Premiere und Final Cut Pro, die brauchen natürlich noch sehr viel mehr Speicher. Und Final Cut Pro ist noch in Karten beschrieben? Ja, das sieht man doch. Ich benutze es nicht, insofern. Ist doch gekaufte Software, so wie iTunes. Das ist Macromedia, war das. Macromedia? Ja, und es sieht immer noch so genau so aus, wie damals alle ekligen Anwendungen bei Macromedia aussahen. Wie Freehand, dieser Seriennummern-Dialog, das ist einfach nicht Mac bis heute nicht. Macromedia ist eine ganz furchtbare Firma gewesen. Ja. Flash, das wurde nicht gekauft von Adobe. Ja, das ist ja der Witz, ja, das ist ja der Witz. Damit sie Flash kriegen. Ich finde Final Cut Pro schon ein tolles Programm, also nicht, dass ich da falsch verstanden werde. Ich finde, das ist irgendwie echt, also ich bin ein Laie im Filmschnitt und ich habe mich da relativ gut zurechtgefunden. Man muss sich da schon so ein bisschen reinlesen und das ist sowieso ein kompliziertes Thema, aber trotzdem, mit diesem User Interface bin ich nie so richtig warm geworden. Und so Sachen wie Aperture, die wirklich von Grund auf Coco sind, da kann ich einfach durchatmen. Aber es sind auch letztlich nur Details. Letztlich wird Apple schon eine Weile daran arbeiten, sie haben natürlich da auch einen Riesenvorsprung jetzt, weil Adobe hat vielleicht sogar schon ein Jahr Arbeit da reingesteckt oder zumindest keine Arbeit in Coco reingesteckt, weil sie sich gedacht haben, naja, 64-Bit wird es auch noch in Zukunft geben, andererseits hätten sie damit auch noch rechnen können. 64-Bit, also die Windows-Version ist natürlich ganz lustig, dass jetzt Photoshop 64-Bit-Windows gibt, das wird wenigen was nützen, weil man muss halt dann auch seinen Vista in 64-Bit-Modus fahren und dann braucht man irgendwie alle seine Programme und vor allem seine Treiber in einem 64-Bit-Modus und die gibt es eigentlich nicht. Ich dachte, Programme würden im 32-Bit-Modus noch laufen, auch unter Windows 64-Bit. Nicht mal das. Sehr traurig. Oder? Ist das so? Ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich blicke bei den 40 verschiedenen Vista-Versionen immer nicht durch. Da nehme ich mich jetzt auch zurück. Da bin ich mir gerade gar nicht so sicher, ob sie noch einen 32-Bit-Backtrott haben für die Anwendung, aber Treiber brauchst du auf jeden Fall neu. Treiber auf jeden Fall, da bin ich mir auch absolut sicher, aber Programme bilde ich mir ein, dass die auch im 32-Bit-Mit. Na gut, dass wir kein Windows-Podcast sind, weil da würden wir ja jetzt mal wirklich nackt darstellen. Da hätte man eine Vista-Sendung machen müssen. Das müssen wir auf jeden Fall noch mal nachreichen. Aber da kennt man eigentlich noch ein schönes Streitthema auf. Du hast die CT fertig gemacht. Oder gehänselt, nicht fertig gemacht. Du hast dich über die CT aufgeregt. Ich habe gesagt, die Hell freezes over. Die CT macht jetzt Macintosh. Stimmt, habe ich auch gesehen. Das ist ein Sonderheft. Was machen die schon lange? Das ist das erste Sonderheft. Das ist das erste Sonderheft. Du kaufst dir eine CT, da weisst du, es gibt so zwei Seiten Macintosh, wo dann irgendwie so fünf Press-Releases stehen und dass irgendein Update von Mac OS X veröffentlicht wurde. Ich finde jetzt ganz putzig, dass immer die Macbooks auch dabei sind, wenn die Laptops getestet werden. Ja, weil da jetzt auch Windows draufläuft. Und, ähm... Mal ehrlich, die CT hat einfach das Macintosh-Thema nicht behandelt. Da mag ab und zu mal was erschienen sein, aber das sind immer so totale, ach ja, da waren ja noch die Macs, dann müssen wir jetzt auch mal was zuschauen. Nee, also ich habe das Gefühl, dass es wirklich in den letzten Jahren deutlich besser geworden ist bei der CT. Ja, es wird immer mehr und jetzt, ich habe ja nur dieses Sonderheft sozusagen als Anlass genommen, um zu sagen, jetzt ist sie schon verfügbar. Ich weiss es nicht, keine Ahnung. Ich hatte überhaupt gar keine Gelegenheit. Ah, okay. Mit einfachem Nein. Ich war nicht in diesem Land. Nein, ich habe sie nicht gekauft. Aber es ist nicht so, dass das eine besondere Würdigung erfahren hat. Ich meine, Macintosh-Teilen in einer Citi, die wirklich jetzt so, was weiss ich, wie eine dicke Fibel ist, da müssen einfach mehr als zwei Seiten einfach drin sein. Es sind viele Themen, die sowohl für Mac als auch für Unix als auch für Windows durchaus ganz interessant sein können, dabei. Und insofern, also die CT finde ich, ähm... Doch, ich verzeuge... Wann hast du die letzte gelesen? Gar keine Frage, dass die CT immer noch eine der besseren Zeitschriften ist. Ich lese die CT immer noch relativ regelmäßig. Ich habe ja auch nicht gesagt, dass die CT schlecht ist. Ah, okay, dann habe ich dich missverstanden. Ja, das habe ich nicht geschrieben. Ich habe nur gesagt, dass es sich irgendwie so um ein Linux- und Windows-orientiertes Blatt handelt, und das sind sie. Ich finde, das Linux-Thema, gut, da gibt es natürlich auch in Deutschland eine riesige Zielgruppe, das ist ja auch vollkommen in Ordnung, bloß wenn ich mir anschaue, was da teilweise einfach in aller Ausführlichkeit berichtet wird, fand ich das einfach häufig Marginalien im Vergleich zu dem, was man auf Macintosh hätte thematisieren können, weil das nun mal ein seriöses Desktop-System ist. Und das ist halt Linux nicht.
In der iX ist jetzt ja auch ein Artikel ein riesengrosches über das iPhone-SDK.
Aha. Na, die Hölle schmilzt richtig.
Ja, das wird. Gibt's bald iPhone-Zeitschriften? Gibt's noch keine.
Einer? Ja, das wäre jetzt meine Frage gewesen. Gibt es welche? Garantiert, ja, es gibt garantiert iPhone-Zeitschriften. Wir werden das recherchieren bis zum nächsten Mal. Die entsprechenden Mac-Zeitschriften werden wahrscheinlich Erfahrung damit haben. Ja, ich nicht. Das sollen auch die Leser machen. Hörer. iPhone-Zeitschriften? Denn es ist definitiv für Outsourcing. Haben wir jetzt das 64-Bit-Thema eigentlich durch? Nee, oder? Ich denke schon. Ja, gut. 64-Bit sind wir durch, ist super. Ja, ich weiss nicht, also wir haben technisch vielleicht den Aspekt weggelassen, der aber eigentlich auch gängig bekannt ist, dass man halt auf dem Macintosh keine 64-Bit-Version des Betriebssystems braucht und es auch keine gibt daher, sondern man kann… Ist schon 64-Bit, so rum. Habe ich jetzt eigentlich ein 64-Bit-Betriebssystem auf meinem Rechner oder nicht? Wie man es nimmt, du hast ein Betriebssystem, das in der Lage ist, 32-Bit- und 64-Bit-Anwendungen auszuführen. Das Betriebssystem selbst ist noch 32-Bit. Und, okay. Also auch auf einem richtigen, ausgewachsenen 64-Bit-Rechner und auch wenn er 16 Gigabyte RAM hat, ist dein Kernel immer noch als 32-Bit compiled, weil sie selber nicht mehr als vier Gigabyte brauchen und weil sie halt kleine Pointer dann auch verwenden und weniger Footprint haben. Also das ist das, was Dennis vorhin meinte. Also 32-Bit heisst halt auch weniger Ressourcen in Anspruch nehmen. Aber sie können halt Anwendungen mit 64-Bit und mit 32-Bit parallel gleichzeitig ohne irgendeine Einschränkung und ohne irgendewindigkeits-Penalty fahren. Das heisst, die Programme können in der Theorie schon mehr Speicher nutzen, sogar für Cocoa, äh Cocoa, und können das dann auch darstellen, was ja bei 10.4 war es nur ohne Gui. Genau, das heisst, wir haben das ganze Cocoa oder Cocoa auf 64-Bit umgemodelt, deswegen gibt es dort jetzt auch nicht mehr den Integer-Typen, also den gibt es schon, sondern sie haben irgendwie so ein Makro, das heisst jetzt NS Integer, glaube ich, und da wird umgeswischt, je nachdem, ob es eine 32- oder eine 64-Bit-Applikation ist, also wir haben da so einen Trick benutzt, um... Klassisches Programmierer-Problem, wie gross ist mein Integer, so bei 64-Bit, aber... Wer hat den grössten? Ja, das haben sie einfach... Weil sie mussten ja ihre ganzen Abends irgendwie anpacken. Programme müssen ja schon wissen, womit sie es zu tun haben, sonst führt das eben schnell dazu, dass sie nicht mehr funktionieren. Aber rein technisch geht das... Wofür steht das NS, was man ständig sieht? Next Step. Next Step! So einfach, dass wir... NS steht für Next Step, ja, weil das... Logisch, also das ist zwar das Kern, also NS-Object ist das höchste Objekt in der Objekt-Hierarchie und das ist sozusagen Teil von Objective-C und Objective-C wurde ja nur auf Next Step überhaupt seriös verwendet und die haben das halt definiert und NS ist sozusagen der Präfix für alles, was Objective-C und alles, was Next Step ist, genau. Ja, ich ahnte, dass es sowas in der Richtung sein würde, aber ich bin niemals auf den naheliegenden Gedanken gekommen. Ja, und Sie haben es nicht in M.O. umbelangt. Sag mal, ist es richtig, dass unser Ex-Hacker, der mit der Lisp-Sendung, dass der jetzt meckert? Das kann ich nicht ausschliessen, ich weiss es nicht. Weil der kannte sich da voll aus. Interessant. Interessanter Hinweis. Ja, so viel zu dem Thema, wir lenken vom einigen Thema ab. Wir waren aber auch fertig, glaube ich. Ich denke, jetzt haben wir es einfach erklärt. Fassen wir mal zusammen, Windows ist doof, Mac OS ist super und Linux ist so lala. Ne, Windows ist voll toll, weil der hat 64-Bit, hat nur keiner und wenn man das entsprechende Windows installiert. Genau. Linux hat auch 64-Bit, muss man halt alles neu compilen. Ja, aber es ist eh auch bei FreeBSD, da habe ich ja auch so ein paar Installationen, da sind inzwischen alles 64-Bit. Also in Bezug auf 32-64-Bit-Flexibilität ist der Mac allen voraus. Also das Problem haben sie wirklich gut gelöst bekommen. Also die Migration findet einfach so statt und man muss keinerlei Klimmzüge machen. Wenn ich mir anschaue, wie das damals bei Windows noch war, als sie von 16 auf 32 betrachtet, das war auch ein jahrelanges Elend. Das war ganz schlimm und blutig und grausam und vielleicht nicht mehr mit ganz so viel Schürfwunden verbunden, aber easy ist das auf jeden Fall nicht. Also das wird noch einige Jahre dauern, bis das bei Windows überhaupt stattfindet. Bei Star, wie auch immer. Also ich meine, das Vista muss ja überhaupt erst mal unter die Leute kommen. Vorher geht da ja gar nichts. Und dann geht das überhaupt erst los, dass 64-Bit-Demand entsteht und dann erst kann man irgendwann mal davon reden, dass man so einen Rechner hat mit 64-Bit. Aber das Windows ist ja auch eben ein Nachteil, weil die haben ja mit ihren Treibern, die müssen ja irgendwie Tausende von Hardware und Trader unterstützen. Da hat ja Apple halt den schicken Vorteil, dass sie halt eine begrenzte Produktpalette haben und das ist halt ein bisschen einfacher. Ja, alles, was sie immer meinten, das wäre ja ganz doof, was Apple da macht, das ist
für Sie heute ein echter grosser Vorteil.
So, jetzt machen wir aber Schlusswahl.
Genau.
Jetzt sind wir nämlich schon fünf Minuten länger als beim letzten Mal.
Ach echt?
Ja.
Das heisst, wir haben jetzt 20 Minuten für 64-Bit gebraucht.
Ja, gut, das wäre nicht 64-Bit.
Minuten dafür gebraucht haben.
Gut, dann lassen wir uns jetzt ganz, ganz schnell
fertig machen. Okay. Dann
bis zum nächsten Mal. Winke, winke. Tschüss.